you I am a great believer that this
house should be informed first I I was I
was unaware of any precedent of a
statement being made on a day set aside
for taking the oath and therefore
unaware that your generosity would have
allowed such a statement to be made
um I I would I would I would point out
to the house that in in my membership of
the house a statement has not been made
by the government during The Taking of
the eighth days set aside nor was any
statement made in 1952 on the last
occasion when the oath was taken so I I
apologize to Mr Speaker well in furnace
what I would say is conversations would
help overcome any of these difficulties
and that's that's why I'm saying Mr
Speaker I am very grateful because I
always think it's important that this
house gets to know
um and that that your generosity in
setting a precedent where statements can
be made on the day set aside for taking
the eighth is I think a good one but it
is vital that businesses have the
support they need to pay their energy
bills this winter Her Majesty's
government his Majesty's government is
determined to grade the economy we
cannot do that if business becomes
insolvent thanks to what is tantamount
to Blackmail by a malevolent State actor
his master's government announced
yesterday that it will be providing a
discount on wholesale gas and
electricity prices for all non-domestic
customers whose current gas and
electricity prices have been
significantly inflated by global Energy
prices this includes all UK businesses
and covers the voluntary sector such as
Charities and the public sector such as
schools and hospitals the scheme will
apply to fixed contracts that have been
agreed on or after the 1st of April 2022
as well as to deemed variable and
flexible tariffs and contracts it will
be applied to energy usage for six
months for the first of October until
the 31st of March next year
as with the energy price guarantee for
domestic customers in order to benefit
from the scheme customers do not need to
take action the discount will
automatically be applied to their energy
bills from the 1st of October in terms
of real-wall savings non-domestic users
will start to see the benefits of the
scheme in their October energy bills
which are typically received in November
the level of price reduction for each
business will vary depending on their
contract type the Tariff and the volume
used we will publish a review Into the
operation of the scheme in three months
to inform decisions on future support
after March 2023 the review will focus
in particular on identifying the most
vulnerable non-domestic customers and
how the government will continue
assisting them with energy costs beyond
the initial six-month period parallel
scheme based on the same Criterion
offering comparable support but
recognizing the different Market
fundamentals will be established in
Northern Ireland those were not
connected to either the gas or
electricity grid equivalent support will
be provided for non-domestic consumers
who use heating oil or alternative fuels
instead of gas further detail on this
will be announced shortly Jonathan
Reynolds
Mr Speaker can I welcome the new
ministerial team to their posts
crisis causes a severe challenge to
businesses of every size many of whom
have been desperate for clarity and
reassurance whilst the conservative
party spent much of the summer
distracted by their own internal drama
on this side of the house we spent that
time arguing that the crisis Demands a
response that is commensurate with the
scale of the challenge paid for by a
windfall tax on the excess profits that
have accrued due to Russia's illegal
invasion of Ukraine
and while I welcome the government
stamosine conversion to freeze Energy
prices
we must all acknowledge for too many
companies this news will already have
come too late to save them businesses
cannot plan on speculation and briefings
and it is regrettable that a minister
who respects the role of parliament
chose to avoid parliamentary scrutiny
and instead opted for a sparse press
release and a short media interview that
is why we have tabled this question to
get the much-needed Clarity on these
plans that businesses desperately need
so can I ask him What specifically will
the review after three months be looking
at and what will the criteria be to
determine whether to extend this support
or not
secondly how will a taxpayer be
protected through energy Traders
inflating prices knowing the government
will be picking up a substantial slice
of those costs Come What May
thirdly what support will he be offering
businesses in the long term to protect
themselves from rising energy costs to
efficiency measures and the transition
to renewable energy
can I also ask him to address the
elephant in the room
who's paying for this
the government says it cannot cost this
package but it's clearly expensive
this government says it can cut taxes
increase spending increase borrowing and
magically pay for that through higher
growth that after 12 years in office has
completely eluded them this Mr Speaker
is fantasy economics and is a threat to
British businesses and the financial
stability of this country
so what can the Secretary of State say
to reassure the country these plans are
robust responsible unfair as well as
sufficient to get us through the crisis
and better protect businesses in the
long term
um thank you Mr Speaker although we have
been away for a few months and had a
leadership election the Socialist record
doesn't change tax tax tax and tax again
it is always the answer to every every
problem so let me come to the specifics
of The Honorable gentleman's question
the three-month review is taking place
to work out who will need support to
ensure that support is properly targeted
what is being done at the moment is an
immediate response to an extreme crisis
to benefit everybody but not everybody
necessarily needs the same level of
support but what we will do in the
review is work out who needs the support
and if I can give some early indications
it seems to me that places like Care
Homes are likely to need longer term
support than that will be covered by the
review and he raises the important
question about how taxpayers will be
protected I have asked the public sector
fraud authority to look at all our plans
to ensure that whatever we are doing and
our mechanisms for paying are as robust
as they can be against the speed with
which we need to act it is really
important to safeguard taxpayers uh
money we are doing a number of things to
help in the Futures market so that the
bank of England and the treasury are
going to provide some underlying capital
for the Futures market so that there is
a more reliable Futures price rather
than the one set on very low liquidity
at the moment and we will legislate on
an expedited fashion to ensure that
anybody who commits fraud against this
is protected against and The Honorable
gentleman raises the issue of transition
gas is a transition fuel the
government's commitment to Net Zero
remains but we will need gas to heat
people's boilers for the immediate
future and we need to get that as
cheaply as we possibly can using all our
domestic resources beyond that there are
exciting plans for carbon capture and
storage and for hydrogen which I think
present a very attractive future for
this country The Honorable gentleman
asks that this
be a responsible robust and fair it is
all it is responsible to protect
business it is robust to ensure that it
can be rolled out quickly and it is fair
to our economy as a whole Julian Smith
um
friends package
um it's already having an effect in
North Yorkshire Angus fire in the small
town of Bentham have emailed this
morning to thank him for this rapid
intervention but could I ask him four
rural areas like North Yorkshire on the
issue of off-grid
um how quickly will businesses hear of
the government's intervention for those
customers
I'm very grateful to my right honorable
friend for his support and I'm glad that
businesses in his uh constituency are
being helped already I recognize the
importance of giving support to those
who off-grid those who are on fuel oil
it's actually particularly an issue in
Northern Ireland of which he has
particular experience as a former
Secretary of State what we are looking
at is the comparables because the
heating oil price has not risen as much
as the gas price and we need to be fair
to all users and we are working on that
currently 10 piece first person sleeping
please thank you Mr Speaker and isn't it
great to see the Secretary of State in
this house rather than standing in the
street filming a statement to the public
surrounded by boarded up shops in a
rubbish what an unedifying spectacle for
a man who believes in the preeminence of
this here Parliament I'm glad he's here
because he's got some questions to
answer and it's about time that he did
so so how much does he anticipate
estimate that this scheme will
ultimately cost including of course
perhaps interest payments can he confirm
that the likes of Amazon will benefit
from this schema scheme that's going to
be built on the back of public sector
borrowing and perhaps most importantly
can he explain to energy users in
Scotland energy rich Scotland where we
produce more oil and gas than we can
possibly consume and where our gas
generation May in our electricity
generation is made up from just 14.4
percent gas why Westminster has failed
us so terribly badly yeah
and Mr Speaker what was it PG Woodhouse
said about it being um not too difficult
to discern the difference between a
Scotsman with a grievance and a ray of
sunshine as so often the SMP comes here
on Thursday mornings with a grievance
and it's rather like old times isn't it
Mr Speaker when I'd have an ally uh on
Thursday mornings to discourse with the
Scottish nationalists about their
General grumpiness and I see that is one
of the constants of British politics he
refers to rubbish in the streets of
Westminster and I'll point out to him
that as soon as an administration's
turns from conservative to socialist the
rubbish piles up in the streets as I
think it's also been doing with the SMP
in Edinburgh
but this this game this game this game
this game is found to taxpayers will
give support across the country and as I
said we are having a review in three
months to ensure that the support goes
to those people who need it most
ly Croft
can I thank my friend for the discussion
he and I have already had our
stands the industry incredibly well now
I'm very grateful to you can he confirm
that energy intensive Industries will be
at the Forefront of government's mind
when we do reach that point of review
here
um thank you Mr Speaker yes indeed
um we are having meetings with British
steel who um will be beneficiaries of
this scheme it is really important that
we don't burden business in this country
in a way that it is not burdened
overseas we must support Great British
businesses
Stephen Kenner thank you Mr Speaker
following on from The Honorable members
question about steel the energy
intensive Industries require
co-investment and partnership with
government in order to make the
transition to cleaner Greener ways of
making steel can the business secretary
confirm that he's committed to
co-investing with Tata steel and our
other steel makers to make that
transition and will he agree to meet
with the all-party Parliamentary group
on steel that I'm proud to chair in
order to set out the government's plans
for this vitally important foundation
industry I I'm very grateful to The
Honorable gentleman and I'm in agreement
with what he says we are in discussions
my officials are in discussions uh with
tartar steel I'd be happy to meet him at
any time and I will make this off at all
honorable and right honorable members I
think it is proper that secretaries of
State make themselves available to all
reasonable requests for meetings from
honorable and right honorable members
across the house Mark Harper Mr Speaker
can I unpress my right honorable friend
on the position of off-grid consumers
around 40 percent of constituents in my
constituency are off the gas grid as
indeed a similar number are in the prime
minister's constituency so this is very
important in the fact sheet updated
yesterday it suggested only a hundred
pounds was going to be provided to such
consumers which doesn't seem like it
delivers a comparable level of support
can you update us when we're going to
have more information secondly do the
electricity companies have an accurate
database of exactly which customers are
on the gas grid and which ones are not
so they're able to make those payments
um thank you Mr Speaker on the second
Point people either have a gas meter or
they don't so that's relatively uh
straightforward as regards the first
point
um the price of heating oil has not
risen by as much as the price of gas and
therefore the aim of government policy
is to ensure equivalence and therefore
inevitably the support given for those
on heating oil will be a lower actual
amount than those uh connected to the
gas grid but that will give them
equivalence yeah mans very grateful Mr
Speaker an aspect of this which hasn't
really been talked about is
um the the the Gas and energy
consultancy companies and in my
constituency of gateshead we've got a
higher than average proportion of energy
consultancy companies based in the
constituency and in The Wider Northeast
region and the impact of the energy
crisis is being felt really hard there
hundreds of energy Consultants jobs have
been lost in the last month of the loan
in gateshead leading to an exodus of
expertise and Innovation that will
further harm business in the future now
the energy the government announcement
the cap Energy prices for the next six
months does nothing to promote the
market competition between suppliers and
leaves brokerage and consultancy
companies Sidelines so however
businesses will ultimately need a return
to the market to improve energy contacts
if they survive through throughout 2023
unless of course the government intends
to change the market model so what plans
does the government have to repair the
energy Market in 2023 and importantly in
the meantime to actually support those
businesses in the northeast or is it
going to be more they will take the
hindmost yeah double gentleman's got to
learn to answer ask a question not make
his own statement
Under The Honorable gentleman might want
to apply for back bench business
committee for debates of this object but
what I what I would say to him is that
the reason we are going for a cap on the
wholesale price is so that the market
should remain as open as possible and
therefore there should be opportunities
for um discussions with companies as to
what the right level of price is at the
retail level and all that goes between
the wholesale to the retail level for
the non-domestic sector so I hope that's
actually helpful to The Honorable
gentleman right
state for a point of clarification on
Park homeowners in Winchester who
obviously live under one business owner
the part-time owner and also people who
live in homes of multiple occupation
under one business owner they were left
wandering for a long time about the 400
pounds rebate previously announced by
the government where do they stand in
respect of this new energy price
guarantee are they being treated as
businesses because if so they're being
treated as business units not domestic
units which of course they are
um thank you Mr Speaker and I'm grateful
to my honorable friend it's an important
question and something
um constituents of all of ours uh will
be concerned about we will legislate to
ensure that the cutting prices is fed
through to Residents so therefore people
running park homes or running Mansion
blocks will have to pass on the benefit
that will be a legal requirement as we
look to the review I think it is very
straightforward to assume that park
homes and Mansion blocks will be at the
Forefront of those who need continued to
support because they are residential
rather than business users Mr Carmichael
thank you Mr Speaker
otley and Shetland already have the
highest levels of fuel poverty in the
country we have no access at all to
means gaskets so so many more of my
constituents rely on heating oil my
constituents are being quoted this
morning one pound 22 Pence per liter for
heating oil it is pretty clear that the
marketing heating oil has failed why is
the government not acting now to bring
heating oil within the price cap
mechanism yeah the the right honorable
gentleman says the government isn't
acting now which isn't entirely accurate
the government is acting now to include
heating oil as I said heating oil hasn't
risen as much as gas obviously we are
working on the basis of the evidence
that is available and we are looking at
the heating oil price
Jesse McCartney thank you Mr Speaker
very much welcome uh this statement
across my calm Valley constituency I
have many small businesses like play
gyms uh gyms cafes in former textile
mills how can we make sure that they're
landlords because they pay one fee for
everything all in are passing on the
benefit of the program that he's
announced today Mr Speaker we will
legislate so that landlords are obliged
to pass on the cutting wholesale prices
Dakota
thank you Mr Speaker there is still a
lot of um Clarity regarding the
government's energy support package for
non-domestic users um businesses faith
and voluntary organizations are
especially worried in my constituency
about the potential Cliff Edge that will
come next April it is not viable for
organizations to plan and six-month
timelines so there needs to be more
clarity and certainty about the scheme
so will the Secretary of State set out
what criteria is going to be used for
those organizations who will qualify for
further additional support come April
next year
Mr Speaker this is exactly what the
review will cover and the review will be
published in plenty of time for the
first of April oh man now
the speaker obviously across the house
we work in this package and we've seen
many similar packages across Europe as a
whole there's been a much further debate
there in Europe about how we also
constrain demand particularly on the
part of industrial users we cannot
subsidize consumption without actually
also under the same time trying to
reduce demand otherwise you're causing
human to risk a blackout to come this
winter
um I'm grateful to my honorable friend
the
price signal remains very strong even
with this support prices have risen
significantly and I think it is fair to
assume that non-domestic users will be
rational actors in the market
there's several robots to prevent
households from being locked into years
of field poverty play Camry are urging
his government to bring forward a
street-by-street insulation program to
be paid for by a higher windfall tax on
oil and gas companies businesses also
need support with Energy Efficiency
measures so that they too can
permanently reduce their energy bills
will he meet with me to discuss the
fsb's proposals for help to Green
vouchers which will support small and
medium-sized businesses to afford energy
saving products and services
um it would be a pleasure to meet The
Honorable lady and to discuss matters
that she would like to raise the
government is committed to helping
people with insulation projects that's
an important part of the government's
strategy and she is right to raise it
William Cates
speaker this support will be very much
welcomed by businesses in my
constituency of peniston and stocks
which particularly high energy users
like steel but the steel industry has
suffered from uncompetitive Energy
prices for years so as welcome as this
short-term help is can my right
honorable friend confirm that he is
looking at a long-term strategy for
steel to make sure that our UK
manufacturers can compete in the long
term oh Mr Speaker I'm in entire
agreement with my honorable friend it
makes absolutely no sense to make
British industry uncompetitive against
Global industry
we now have a Secretary of State for
business and industry who's never worked
in industry or in business it is an
investment is an investment banker
and can I tell him that small firms and
big firms in Huddersfield will go bust
we'll go bust with the energy levels of
cost of energy this winter and has he
seen the front page the financial times
this is a crisis for our country
especially in manufacturing when will he
do something wake up to his
responsibility but to get out there in
the country and talk to manufacturers
Mr Speaker I think it's the honorable
gentleman who needs to wake up and pay
attention to what has been announced
for many businesses including jungle
Kingdom in my constituency solar panels
are a way to make a significant tangible
difference in the long term but they
cannot secure the permission of their
landlord what measures could be
considered to make it work for both
parties
um my old friend raises an important
point that landlords and tenants need to
work together to try and ensure that
efficient sources of energy are achieved
normally it will be in the interests of
landlords to use have solar panels
applied particularly if the tenant is
volunteering to pay for them so I think
this is something where the market can
probably find an answer
Smith got Smith
speaker many small businesses in The
Loon Valley and over wiresdale and my
constituency use heating oil and whilst
the price of this has not increased as
much or as fast as the gas price it has
still increased exponentially and many
small businesses are really struggling
to know how they're going to make ends
meet so can I ask the Secretary of State
and how soon will these businesses get
any clarification whatsoever from this
government about whether or not they're
going to still be in business at
Christmas
Mr Speaker the heating oil issue is an
important one for her constituents for
businesses and as I mentioned earlier
for Northern Ireland it is therefore
important that we make sure there is a
proper equivalent scheme and that's what
we're doing at Barrington
you Mr Speaker many businesses in my
constituency welcome very much these
measures and as a number of members have
already said energy intensive Industries
particularly have been at the brunt of
many of the issues that we've faced with
energy cost Rises so will my right more
friend look at particularly Industries
like Ceramics look at that longer term
support and particularly look at how we
can support those Industries to invest
in more efficient and energy saving
Technologies
yes this is a very important point for
the Ceramics industry for the steel
industry and for other high energy
intensive industries that they want to
move to more efficient means of
production and this may require some
investment and it's important that the
government helps work on schemes to
ensure that we have vibrant efficient
profitable and most importantly of all
globally competitive Industries Airline
Lucas thank you
the Secretary of State's announcements
may have finally put a temporary break
on further terrifying price hikes but it
leaves huge questions unanswered
including what is the government's exit
strategy we need a proper solution to
get us out of this crisis by reducing
dependence on gas and upgrading
buildings for the long term just
yesterday over a hundred top businesses
wrote to the government begging them for
support for Energy Efficiency and
large-scale Industrial industrial
decarbonization can he explain why they
were so conspicuous by their absence in
his in his measures announced today and
will he remedy that now
Mr Speaker the businesses that write can
Implement their own Energy Efficiency
measures that's what businesses do it's
a sensible investment for them because
if they become more energy efficient
they will save cash on their energy
bills but I would also say what we need
is more secure and cheaper supplies of
gas that's why we're going to issue more
licenses it's why we're looking at Shale
gas it is really important that people
have confidence that gas will flow
through the pipes and into their boilers
say that they can heat their homes
during this and succeeding Winters well
Paul said Thank you Mr Speaker at a time
when they're facing very substantial
increases in a key cost of operating
businesses across the UK have welcomed
the measures and particularly the speed
with which the government has responded
I wonder whether the Secretary of State
saw the remarks of Kate Nichols of
hospitality UK who praised the
inclusiveness of this scheme by bringing
in both small and large companies and
drawing attention to how this is
actually going to secure jobs in the
long term because I'm I'm very grateful
to my honorable friend for his question
that it is fundamentally important that
we had a rapid scheme that protected as
many businesses as possible because the
increase is so extreme that on an
immediate view of it it was hard to see
any business that would find conditions
that easy with this level of increase
and therefore we had to act quickly and
universally and I'm very grateful for
his support and for that of the
hospitality industry Hillary Ben
it's a real small Charities that are not
registered with the charity commission
be eligible for this assistance I'm
thinking of those with an income of less
than five thousand pounds a year that
cannot register voluntarily and are not
required to do so will they get help as
well the
help all non-domestic users the only
exception is the gas powered electricity
generation operators who will not get
the subsidy for their electricity
Generation all other non-domestic
outlets will be benefited so Ben Spencer
thank you Stephen I welcome
um this package will support to
businesses and Safeguard jobs in
Runnymede and weighbridge of course the
current Situation's exacerbated by an
energy Market doesn't work
um and the need for further investment
in terms of nuclear and Renewables and
I'm glad the government's Consulting on
the former and investing in the latter
does my writable friend agree with me
that it's public and private investment
that's needed along with a functioning
energy Market to ensure we never have to
face the situation again
uh yes my uncle friend's absolutely
right uh we need a better functioning
energy Market their real difficulties uh
with the liquidity in the Futures Market
at the moment he's also right that we
need a further and faster rollout of
nuclear energy and that is being worked
on
um and that um offshore wind which is
going at a rapid Pace continues to be a
major source of energy and a growing
source of energy within this country
Carla lockup
her the secretary of state has mentioned
Northern Ireland several times
throughout the course of the statement
uh highlighting that he is aware that a
large number of small businesses in
Northern Ireland rely on oil for heating
their premises can the Secretary of
State go further than just a throwaway
line and confirm that the inadequate and
insignificant 100 Pine being offered to
high souls for oil will be reviewed and
that the same figure will not be offered
to businesses reliant on oil yeah
um Mr Speaker two-thirds of Northern
Ireland households are um not on gas and
therefore it is fundamental to ensure
that Northern Ireland is treated fairly
and as a full part as it is of the
United Kingdom that is an absolute
priority of the United Kingdom and
Northern Ireland does not have the price
cap that applies in Great Britain and
therefore we will need to bring forward
legislation to deal with the issues in
Northern Ireland which we will do as a
matter of absolute priority to ensure
that a scheme is up and running rapidly
and we are very conscious as other
members have raised about the fuel oil
issue
thank you Mr Speaker on the heating oil
issue two-thirds of my constituency live
off the gas grid I note what the
secretary of state says about being fair
to all Bill payers but I would urge him
not to fall into the Trap that rural
areas are wealthy areas fuel poverty in
my constituency is a serious problem and
so far the only support that's been
announced is a hundred pounds which will
provide heating oil for just 10 days it
will not touch the sides can I urge the
government to rethink on rural areas in
heating oil
um Mr Speaker I'm grateful to The
Honorable lady and representing a rural
constituency uh personally I am well
aware that there are areas of our
Countryside that suffer from fuel
poverty I would say to my honorable
friend that it is all a matter of
proportionality that is what we are
striking to achieve and to get that
balance right
a businessman contacted my office
recently extremely distressed concerned
about the future of his business he does
engineering and he was talking about
closing his doors for good and laying
off 50 people so I hope the minister
accepts her not only has the delay in
hearing something from government caused
emotional distress but also an impact on
the local economy because businesses are
not making future decisions for
investment in Workforce or in their
business when they're not sure that they
have a future so bearing that in mind
will the minister offer that greater
reassurance by giving businesses
long-term support to improve their
energy efficiency
a very significant package of support
has been announced and it's been brought
forward as early as was practicable I
mentioned that a review will take place
and the point of the review is to work
out who is going to be in most need of
that support
Tom Hunt
speaker I very much welcome this package
of support for business like I did for
domestic users I was contacted yesterday
however by Resident Orwell key the
neighbor said I've experienced a 300
increase in the service charge to heat
the communal areas my constituent Alan
wanted to know whether the government
has a plan to support leaseholders in
places such as oil key and Ipswich
today Mr Speaker we will legislate to
ensure that the reduction in the
wholesale cost is fed through to people
who are in Mansion blocks or or For Whom
the
um energy is being bought centrally and
then charged on a service charge it is
going to be a fundamental part of these
proportions
thank you Mr
chair at Calder Miller Field in my
constituency have been quoted a 345
increase in their electricity costs
alone well I appreciate what it's his
plans maybe to help him in the next six
months what can he offer them after the
end of that six months because 345
increase in just electricity course
could put this business under
um Mr Speaker The Honorable lady raises
the point that I think was concerning
MPS across the house of these
extraordinary large Rises and that's why
we've brought forward this package I'm
trying to give as much reassurance as I
can without preempting the review as I
said we have done this on a completely
broad brush basis because at the moment
that is the right thing to do it is
needed urgently however we do need to
examine exactly who ought to benefit in
a review and then have that announced in
plenty of time for the first of April to
see what level of support is needed for
the longer term Simon Jeff
thank you Mr Speaker many businesses in
East Devon have already welcomed the
support outlined by my right or Revenge
but as as he well knows
um the hospitality industry in
particular will need targeted support
after that six-month period will he
commit to working continue to work with
the industry and the old party
parliamentary group of which I chair on
a wider package that will help hubs and
cafes survive after six months
um Mr Speaker I'm very happy to consider
representations to the review from my
honorable friend and from others
regarding specific Industries Chris
Bryant thank you Mr Speaker and the
trouble with announcing a measure which
only lasts for six months is that local
authorities are quite responsibly
putting together their budgets for next
year now look my local Authority has
said to me that if this is not renewed
for next year because they run swimming
pools and Leisure centers and Care Homes
and schools and so on it will be the
single biggest blow to their finances in
50 years and they would have to start
laying people off pretty sharp so will
the Secretary of State make sure that
local authorities are given plenty of
advance notice on how their budgets can
be protected for the next financial year
um Mr Speaker I've laid out when the
review will be and that we will give as
much later as we can prior to the first
of April Aaron Bell Mr Speaker could I
thank my honorable friend for a
statement which I know will be welcomed
across Newcastle underlying both in our
hospitality industry but also the
brickworks at Chesterton which is energy
intensive does he agree with me that we
must not be in this position again in
future indeed Western Europe must not be
in this position again and that will
require investment not only in diverse
diversifying our energy but also in
storage and what will his Department do
to work on energy storage
um Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
right we must not be in this position
again that is why we want to ensure that
we maximize our own domestic sources of
energy and we look at long-term
contracts with friendly Nations across
the world who are fundamentally more
reliable but yes there is a great deal
more to do and storage is something that
we are looking at
thank you Mr Speaker the Scottish
license trade Association have said of
the government's plans when you look
beyond the headlines it doesn't live up
to the hype as this new scheme caps the
wholesale price and pubs and clubs could
be paying two to three hundred percent
higher bills than normal the newly and
extensively restored Foundry Pub in
Inverness has had to close its doors a
few weeks ago citing energy costs is a
key reason during the Tory leadership
vacuum does a secretary of state accept
that what he is offering businesses as
too little too late and doesn't last
long enough
no I wouldn't
um characterize it that way at all I'd
simply say that if Scotland were
independent it wouldn't be able to
afford to do any of this
Virginia Crossman thank you Mr Speaker
Anglesey is known as energy Island we
have wind wave solar hydrogen and
hopefully new nuclear at Wilbur yeah and
yet we have one of the lowest gvas of
any constituency across the UK can my
right honorable friend reassure my
constituents that this package will help
um will help protect their jobs but help
bring much needed new employment and
investment and skilled jobs to Anglesey
um Mr Speaker that is something I'd be
extremely Keen to see happen though I
would also add that in his mon has a
very high energy Dynamo as a member of
Parliament
humble friend about local authorities
position uh come December the Secretary
of State for dealer will make a spending
announcement about local authorities for
next year with the secretary agreed that
his review of energy costs should be
incorporated into that so local
authorities get one presentation of what
the future is going to look like rather
than a myriad of different ones not
joined up together
Mr Speaker I think the honorable
gentleman is rather looking a gift horse
in the mouth that this is providing a
very significant reduction in Energy
prices for the next six months and a
review will take place to see what
happens next local authorities would be
in a very difficult financial situation
if this were not being done but the
government cannot the government cannot
responsibly commit to unended
expenditure it has to be done in a
sensible and proven fashion
sneaker I warmly welcome the package of
measures my writable friend has set out
but as the number of questions this
morning has indicated the one area that
does need more detail and dare I say to
polish is the off-grid question so can I
urge my right Uncle friend when he looks
to the detail of off-grid support for
businesses and households he doesn't
treat it just as one that looks at the
disparity in pricing between oil and LPG
which are very different cost bases and
need to be treated separately
indeed Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
Right LPG has not risen as much as
natural gas
um and um heating oil has not risen as
much as natural gas either but it is
important to make sure that there is
fairness for everybody and bear in mind
some houses and indeed some schools are
still dependent on coal for their
heating Monera Wilson
very much Mr Speaker yesterday's
announcement provided very little
certainty for schools and other public
services that simply pushed the cliff
Edge back by six months schools in my
constituency are already facing
difficult decisions about cutting
support staff for instance but they also
need help cutting energy usage and this
government shut down the school's Energy
Efficiency loan scheme which helps them
to buy insulation and solar panels and
so on so isn't it high time the
Secretary of State looked at reopening
that scheme
Elizabeth on the first point that we are
providing considerably more certainty
than would otherwise be provided in a
fundamentally uncertain energy market
price
um we obviously encourage people to look
at ways in which they can insulate
themselves better and are in Endless
discussions to ensure that we can have
the appropriate programs David
this is across Grantham and Stanford
will welcome the support announced this
week lincolnshire's farmers in
particular are facing increasing
pressure owing to the rise of cost of
inputs like fertilizer and energy so
will he assure me that he will remain
mindful of the particular circumstances
farmers face in the design of any future
support packages
Mr Speaker as I also represent an
agricultural constituency I am very
conscious of the needs of farmers which
should be at the Forefront of the
nation's care and concern
thank you Mr Speaker in times of Crisis
we have turned to our civil society
organizations to support us with vital
services and across the Arts now we're
expecting museums Galleries and theaters
to provide the public with warm banks
these critical community and cultural
organizations tell me they are facing
combined challenges falling donations
and incomes Rising costs and the
continuing impact of covid so can the
business secretary tell us what can he
tell us to reassure these essential
organizations that support for energy
costs will extend for them Beyond six
months
Mr Speaker I think I've already answered
the question in relation to what happens
after six months there will be a review
and what is going to happen will be
announced well in advance of the 1st of
April
thank you Mr Speaker I welcome this
statement from the Secretary of State on
behalf of the thousands of businesses
Charities but also the 63 Care Homes and
30 schools in south and west but when he
comes to his review would the Secretary
of State assure me that he will keep in
mind the particular needs of special
schools of which we have brilliant ones
in South End Kingstown in particular
they look after the most seriously
disabled children their energy needs are
much higher due to the feeding pumps and
the hoists would he agree to sit down
with me and discuss their special needs
when he comes to his review
I would be delighted to discuss this
with my honorable friend and in my own
constituency we have the fossway school
as a special school which provides a
wonderful and caring service to children
in very great need Kim Jones Thank you
Mr Speaker the secretary of state has
mentioned that there will be support for
the voluntary in the charitable status
in my Liverpool Riverside constituency
we have a number of food banks and food
pantries and they're struggling to keep
their doors open and this um providing
essential services for people forced
into poverty so can the Secretary of
State tell us what level of support
beyond the six months will be available
to this very important sector thank you
so Mr Speaker I have already answered
several times the question on what will
happen after the first of April
businesses in Hinckley and Bosworth
we're hugely grateful for the protection
the government's put in place there is
one problem though with world events
what is the government's assessment of
the risk of energy blackouts and should
businesses prepare for energy blackouts
Mr Speaker there is a requirement for a
study of that to be provided and I
believe a study will be provided in
early October on in relation to our
energy security through the winter
thanks Matt
thank you Mr Speaker parts of Blaine
gwent are 1200 feet above sea level and
our Winters can be bitter so will there
be any extra help for families facing
higher bills in constituencies with much
colder weather than most and also will
the government look again at the cold
weather payment criteria as part of its
upcoming review
Mr Speaker cold weather payments is not
a responsibility of my department but I
will ensure that his comments are passed
on to the relevant social studies
many other MPS I spent the summer
visiting small businesses and charities
in my constituency and what they all see
is that the need to be able to make
forward plans for example Foursquare a
charity in my constituency run a hostel
for homeless young people a women's
refuge and they also fundraise from a
large retail premises
and these soaring energy bills may
affect their ability to keep the
homeless hostel and the women's Refuge
open yeah and the fact is it's simply
not practical for them to wait three
months for a review they need action and
information on the government's
long-term plans before three months are
up so will the Secretary of State please
seriously reconsider the timing year and
listen to voices across the house urging
them to do that
um Mr Speaker we have acted extremely
swiftly to provide support it is proper
that this should be reviewed to ensure
it goes to the right people the timeline
is completely reasonable and it really
does seem to me Mr Speaker that people
are looking for things for a package
that they broadly welcome to harp onabad
many businesses are negotiating
contracts now with their energy
suppliers so what has he got to say to
those businesses should they just
negotiate just for six months what is it
going to do in all urgency to prevent
event this next six months just being a
period when businesses run down to the
closing in six months time yeah yeah
um Mr Speaker as I've said hi there will
be a review and there will be an
announcement giving people plenty of
time for the first of April
school thank you Mr Speaker many
churches and Charities are going to be
expending more energy over the coming
months because they're providing warm
banks in the constituency so what
additional support will they be able to
apply for to be able to provide the
resilience to our community's needs
um Mr Speaker this support is
comprehensive across the non-domestic
sector in Paisley
okay the secretary has indicated the
clarity that many companies now require
in Northern Ireland that legislation
will not be required to assist
businesses that thousands of businesses
in Northern Ireland are small and
medium-sized Enterprises they actually
currently apply for legislation so I'm
wondering if the secretary can now
commit to an emergency instrument or
provision before December of this year
um Mr Speaker
um this house when called upon can act
remarkably swiftly the intention is that
we should introduce legislation in
October and pass it by the end of
October and that it should take effect
from the 1st of October to ensure that
businesses in the whole of the United
Kingdom or non-domestic users in the
whole of the United Kingdom are helped
but that everybody in Northern Ireland
should be helped as well that is the
broad time frame and I hope that the
house will cooperate with that timetable
because obviously that is necessary for
expedited legislation still love me
thank you Mr Speaker we've seen so many
big energy companies post obscene
profits while constituents businesses
Charities schools across my vocal
constituency continue to suffer since
the government was so reluctant to
introduce the windfall tax can a
minister please confirm how the
government will ensure that the energy
companies will become power to pass on
this subsidy to their businesses
Mr Speaker course depends what you mean
by the energy companies because the
domestic suppliers have not been making
enormous amounts of money and indeed
many of the energy suppliers went on
business over the last few months so um
they haven't been making vast amounts of
money some businesses have been making a
lot of money they pay very significant
amounts of tax already and it is really
important that we don't assume there is
some Honeypot of businesses that can be
raided there isn't we need long-term
investment in this country to maximize
the exploration and production of oil
and gas to ensure that we have lower
prices and sustainable businesses that
is not aided by putting taxes on at
every opportunity which the Socialists
always want to do
[Applause]
the domestic scheme is based on a loan
to be repaid out of future bills it's
the business scheme is to be repaid in
the same way why would businesses not
regard this as a tax rise deferred and
if it's not is the business secretary
really really expecting it to be repaid
out of General taxation by the rest of
the taxpayers tax tax tax is what he
said
economic growth economic growth economic
growth
Andrew Gwen yes
and raised the plan
to fly through a tumultuous time through
the pandemic and many small Hospitality
Outlets are facing extortionate
increases in their bills Howard's
neighborhood bar a small 60 seat bar in
Denton is facing their bills increasing
by 2 000 pounds a month that is just not
sustainable for them whilst this support
takes them six months down the road they
will be worried about what happens there
I know the secretary of state says there
will be a review but can he offer a
glimmer of hope to businesses like
Howard's neighborhood bar that they
won't face that Cliff Edge in six months
time thank you Mr Speaker and The
Honorable gentleman asks a very fair
question I cannot preempt the review but
I think I can offer a glimmer of hope
because what we have to do in the review
is see those companies that need the
greatest support and other non-domestic
users I've indicated some of them it
seems to me with without going too far
that the hospitality sector is one that
is at particular risk in this area if
you would like to make representations
to the review I will listen to them very
carefully London
as well as business is a number of
housing associations of concerns about
energy places and all small glasgowskins
that you can see I've got over 15 000
associations many of which have the
unique tenements their properties which
are very difficult when it comes to
Energy Efficiency would the Secretary
State be willing to come to Glass beast
and take part in our room table with
local housing associations and
understand the challenges that termit
properties in particular face during the
energy crisis the audible Journal who
now so often raises a serious point but
we are very conscious of the issues
facing social housing landlords
particularly that those which have some
rather older housing stock that are the
least energy efficient and there are
important things to be done in helping
them and make their housing more
efficient and there have been schemes
available to do that I'm not sure I can
promise a visit but I'd be delighted to
discuss this with him further Margaret
Greenman
thank you Mr Speaker
um care homes in my constituency are
facing soaring energy costs I'm sure the
minister will be aware and they look
after frail and vulnerable people and
it's essential that they're kept warm I
note The Minister's comments thus far on
Care Homes but can he give us an
assurance that there will be a real
focus on ensuring their ongoing
Financial viability
Mr Speaker this is obviously a
fundamental concern to his Majesty's
government
and I want to try again on local
authorities because I'm not sure the
minister understands that the review is
simply too late too many councils
already are facing budget holds Luton
Council 10 million pounds budget hold
this year because of increasing energy
costs inflation represses and increasing
demands so has the minister had any
conversations with the Secretary of
State for local government dluck about
the budget planning process because
local authorities are required to
produce medium-term budgets before April
next year
Mr Speaker the degree of certainty that
is being offered is greater than there
is in a normal year we are saying that
what will happen will be announced after
the three-month review has taken place
in plenty of time for the first of April
normally local authorities are dependent
on the visitudes of the market
that's a great day
I've spoken to in Glasgow North are
already operating on tightness of
margins and if they go out of business
that has a lot a knock-on effect across
the local economy so the poverty rate
spirals up rather than wealth trickling
down so what assurances can he give to
these businesses rather than simply
pushing the cliff Edge further down the
roads
Mr Speaker I think we've given a very
substantial Assurance this morning
this twist
uh Winton Court sheltered housing scheme
run by housing 21 and they explained to
me how angry they were that they were
not benefiting from the domestic subsidy
so can the Secretary of State tell me
how he proposes to make sure that those
people most of them pensioners are not
hit by increased energy costs are in no
worse positions than other residents so
I'm very grateful to The Honorable lady
who is such an assiduous campaigner for
her constituents and she's absolutely
right that we have to ensure that these
wholesale price carts do feed through
um to the people that they're meant to
benefit and that will be in our
legislation named Daniel Johnson
quickly on energy costs smithy's fish
and chip shop which have been trading
for 38 years on Beverly Road in Hull had
to close its doors not just because of
energy cost increases but the price of
fish has gone up 120 and the price of
beef dripping 150 so I'd like to know
from the Secretary of State what more
he's going to do to reassure the one of
the institutions at the heart of our
communities fish and chip shops
Mr Speaker I'm glad to reassure people
about fish and chip shops which um The
Honorable lady indeed is right to say
are at the heart of our community
because they will benefit from this
Universal scheme girl Monaghan
speaker and businesses in Glasgow
Northwest can literally see the turbines
that are produced in Scotland's
renewable energy they are not feeling
supported at the moment so can the
Secretary of State confirm that the
businesses that have been supported most
through this uh crisis are the energy
producers gas and oil companies
no that's a complete misunderstanding
what is happening what we are happening
is all non-domestic users in addition to
domestic users we're protecting
businesses and individuals and Charities
across the country
um lots of smes in South Manchester are
still really worried and can I make a
particular plea for
um small and medium-sized bakeries on
Martins and like Barbican and Charlton
my constituents have been in touch I
mean really concerned can you show us
that he's in discussions with those kind
of energy intensive small businesses and
and can we just make a plea that that
doesn't have to wait for three months I
hope those discussions are going on now
yeah
um Mr Speaker all businesses will be
benefiting but obviously the more energy
intents of the business the more it will
benefit from this reduction in wholesale
prices and as I've said I'm very open to
receive from honorable and right
honorable members representations uh to
the review that is taking place and
McLaughlin
because I'm a member of the voluntary
Board of the Scottish Pantry Network and
our shops are significantly
Empire Rising it costs the Pancho
Network exists for environmental reasons
to stop food waste but primarily it
exists to provide low-cost Fresh Foods
for people who can't afford Supermarket
prices to keep the food fresh our shops
have walk-in fridges and walk-in
freezers and they cost a lot of money to
run does he not see the situation
whereby some of those supermarkets that
my constituents can't sharpen making
massive profits will be helped by this
but some of my pantry shops won't be
simply because they signed up to a
contract prior to the first of April
will he remove that date and if not at
the three-month review will he at least
consider including all of those
non-domestics that signed up to contact
us before the first of April in their in
the review yeah yeah Mr Speaker the
major price rises in contracts took
place after the first of April which is
why the first of April date was set
but Western thank you Mr Speaker for the
last 12 years the government has had the
chance to act on energy Supply and
infrastructure businesses around the
country have been saying to me uh
manufacturing businesses that they are
facing a 59 premium against the EU
average for electricity so why has the
government not acted sooner certainly
before this energy Spike and actually
ensured the security of UK businesses
yeah yeah Mr Speaker it is very
important for our economy that we have
competitive Energy prices that we don't
go out of our way to a burden British
business I agree that The Honorable
gentleman is right to be campaigning for
lower energy prices Patricia Gibson
Mr Speaker the energy package announced
today is as it is is fine as late as it
is and as far as it goes and the
secretary of state has heard widespread
concerns about a cliff Edge in this
support in three or six months time
in view of the concerns race today will
he give further and Urgent consideration
to additional support for energy
intensive business sectors such as
manufacturing and Hospitality as well as
longer term support for investing in
energy saving measures
Mr Speaker I think we've covered most of
that already and the answer is broadly
yes
speak to Grant
Mr Speaker the second estate admitted a
few minutes ago that we've all known for
at least six months that Arjun a major
government intervention is going to be
needed why is it taking so long and
calling back his experience and
knowledge and the way things work from
his previous post who does he think this
is should the man come start the
spatchbox to apologize to her
constituents for six months unnecessary
delayed
Mr Speaker most energy is used during
the winter we've got plans ready for the
winter Wendy Chamberlain Mr Speaker
another Secretary of State acknowledged
the importance of farming in response to
an earlier question but we know in terms
of food supply it's not just Farmers
it's factories and those involved in
food production and that's certainly the
case in Northeast Fife further food and
inflation will only impact struggling
families more so although the short-term
energy support is welcome there are
other issues for the sector such as cost
of fertilizer labor Supply
etc etc etc will the government commit
to a cross-government strategy involving
defra the home office of Treasury and
bees to ensure that we ensure our food
supply for the future
Mr Speaker The Honorable lady's right to
raise what is going on with the cost of
living more generally energy is a very
important part of that and helping deal
with the energy problem will have an
effect on price Rises throughout the
economy the bank of England I think is
going to be saying something later on
today which is another part of dealing
with inflation but I accept her analysis
that inflation is a very difficult
problem for an economy to face Jim shum
Mr Speaker can I thank the sector very
much for his commitment and has helped
for all the different uh sectors across
the whole of my community I met a
business in Monday from my committee
employs over 200 people it's a very
energy intensive Factory business is
figures for his energy and a year or a
six-figure sum on the large side he
needs help right away they secure those
jobs and ensure that that the future is
secure for his home in his company can I
ask again the secretary to clarify
please will he qualify for that 50 help
towards energy costs in particular for
electric
um Mr Speaker
I don't know the circumstances of an
individual company but if the company is
on Maine's gas it will benefit and it
will benefit from the 1st of October and
the an electric uh it will benefit in
Northern Ireland both Gas and Electric
will be almost identical for technical
reasons slightly different but same in
effect as what goes on in GB
we now come to the exchange of question
another man
thank you speaker to ask the Secretary
of State for business energy and
Industrial strategy to make a statement
regarding the lifting of the moratorium
on Shale gas extraction
thank you uh Mr Speaker and what a
pleasure it is to be continuing
um on this uh theme
and indeed the the
the the the the
honorable lady is right to be saying to
me that I need to find the right page
because I am
I am having some difficulty in finding
the right page uh immediately
um
don't worry
um
is there another copy we can send to it
or the Secretary of State Mr Speaker I'm
very grateful to the right honorable
gentleman for uh bringing forward his
urgent question and I'm glad to be able
to announce that the moratorium on
extraction of shale gas is being lifted
and a statement has been laid before the
house to do this as I was setting out in
the previous
urgent question it is important that we
use all available sources of fuel within
this country it is more environmentally
friendly if you use our own sources of
fuel rather than to extract them from
other countries and transport them here
at Great cost both financially and in
terms of carbon it is something
therefore that we need to visit and we
need to revisit the seismic limits to
ensure that Shale gas extraction can be
done in an effective and efficient way
Mr Speaker this is obviously a case of
the dog ate my homework and who uh and
and he's hardly surprising let's start
by taking his excuse for lifting the
fracking ban Mr Speaker that it will
make a difference the energy bills
crisis it won't because gas is sold on
the international market the current
Chancellor the current Chancellor said
so in February of this year and I quote
no amount of shale gas would be enough
to the to lower the European price of
gas even Mr Speaker the founder of
quadrilla said the secretary of state is
wrong in an article published yesterday
so first why doesn't he admit the truth
that anyone who knows anything about
this subject says his claim that
fracking will cut bills is nonsense next
let's come to safety the 2019 Manifesto
on which he and every member of the
party opposite stood said this said this
uh Mr Speaker we will not support
fracking unless the science shows
categorically that it can be done safely
they are lifting the ban but they can't
Supply the evidence and the British
Geological Survey published today
certainly doesn't do it so in the
absence of the evidence his approach is
to change the safety limits he says in
his written statement lay before this
house tolerating a higher degree of risk
and disturbance appears to us to be in
the National interest
I look forward to him and his colleagues
explaining his Charter for earthquakes
to the people of Lancashire Yorkshire
the Midlands Sussex Dorset and indeed
Somerset who will be part of his
dangerous experiment let me tell the
party opposite we will hang this broken
promise round their necks in every part
of the country between now and the next
general election the conservative
Manifesto also said having listened to
local communities we have ruled out
changes to the planning system does he
stand by that promise and how will he
abide by the prime Minister's commitment
to local consent the truth is he doesn't
get this that you can't escape a fossil
fuels crisis by doubling down on fossil
fuels Renewables are today nine times
cheaper than gas the only way to cut
energy bills that energy security is
with zero carbon homegrown power
including onshore wind and solar which
his wing of the conservative party hates
and he continues to block for
communities in every part of our country
today's shows they can never trust a
word this government says again and he
is shown he is willing to break his
promises to support dangerous Fringe
ideas that put the interest of fossil
fuel companies above that of the British
people
this thing
[Applause]
Mr Speaker there was plenty of energy in
that but it was I'm afraid uh more Sound
and Fury that signifies nothing
we know that Shale gas is safe it's safe
in the United States and has been one of
the biggest contributors and has been
one of the biggest contributors to the
decline in carbon emissions in the
United States of any activity that has
gone on in that country
we know we know even if members opposite
wish to ignore it that seismic activity
of 2.5 and Below on the Richter Scale
takes place millions of times a year
across the world that are standards for
our standards for
um ground level movements for
construction work are double those that
have ever been achieved by any Shale gas
exploration in this country there is a
huge margin over what we allow for
building work against what has actually
happened in terms of shale gas and The
Honorable gentleman seeks to deny the
ordinary rules of supply and demand he
ought to be aware he ought to be aware
that when you increase supply and demand
remains steady you have an effect on
pricing and that pricing is always set
at the margin the that the price of any
commodity is set by the final user who
demands that commodity and if Supply
exceeds demand then price is full and
any increase in Supply helps reduce
costs but there's another point we have
all of us constituents with gas boilers
and we are going to have them for many
years to come do we really want them to
be dependent on strange dictatorships
that wage war in this cut in this world
or do we want to have our own security
our own supplies do we want to maximize
what we receive from the North Sea and
what we receive from underneath our feet
this seems to me Mr Speaker to be just
good common sense it is safe it is shown
to be safe the scare stories have been
disproved time and again the hysteria
about seismic activity I think fails to
understand that the Richter scale is
another rhythmic scale it seems to think
it is a straight arithmet scale which of
course it is not and bringing on this
Supply will bring us cheaper energy
which we need that will help our
constituents it secures our
s which will ensure that our businesses
can continue to operate whatever the
weather this is of such importance and
it is
Mr Speaker that opposes it
it's nothing laudate about the people of
Lancashire are of filed and I just want
to start by saying Mr Speaker how
disappointed I am that Parliament was
not informed about this before the media
that as a local Member of Parliament I
was not given the courtesy despite
having requested for two weeks
contacting The Honorable member to get
information via's PPS I've said letters
I've sent whatsapps nothing back so Mr
Speaker can we be crystal clear on one
thing the prime minister or the
Manchester hustings it's a matter for
public record you can find the clip made
it crystal clear no ifs no buts no
caveats that fracking would only take
place in the United Kingdom where there
was local consent
crystal clear so if the prime minister
is to remain a woman of our word a woman
that we can believe in which I believe
she is can the Secretary of State
outline how that local consent will be
given and demonstrated in my contingency
of fires
um Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman uh
would have heard my right old friend the
prime minister in Her speech
um on energy on the um 8th of September
saying that we were lifting the
moratorium on fracking so I'm surprised
that he feels he wasn't informed because
that has been announced we obviously
want to work with local communities and
it is really important that the
companies who seek to extract Shale gas
come up with packages that make what
they're proposing to do welcome to local
communities that is a fundamental
importance and is what the Prime
Minister has set up Stephen Flynn SNP
spokesperson yes Mr Mr Speaker there can
be no doubt that this particular
political earthquake is absolutely
bonkers the UK faces two problems when
it comes to energy energy prices and
energy security let's be clear when it
comes to Energy prices producing Shale
gas will make absolutely no difference
whatsoever and when it comes to energy
security what this government could and
should be doing is Turbo charging
Renewables and creating a cfd for the
likes of hydrogen to ensure that we have
hydrogen boilers in the future not
relying upon gas boilers of the past but
luckily Mr Speaker in Scotland there
will be no change there will be no
fracking whatsoever we unlike the Tories
stick to our work and it's great to know
that that will not change but the one
thing that will change is will be long
gone from the shackles of this place by
the time Shale gas is produced in
England
Mr Speaker it's amusing to think that
the economics of Independence were all
dependent upon oil and gas and now
they're not going to have any so that
doesn't seem to me to be entirely uh
consistent
using our national resources is a
sensible and wise policy and that is
what this government is looking to do so
Desmond sway there's been no moratorium
on fracking for thermal energy and it's
continued a pace at many sites but the
science is the same isn't it
so Mr Speaker except thermal energy has
no seismic limit on it whereas there was
a 0.5 limit on Shale gas which made it
almost impossible it was a policy that
was designed to stop any Shell Gas being
extracted in library
you Mr Speaker Company
secondary steer confirm what recoverable
reserves of Shield gas we have here in
the UK what percentage of nutshell gas
um would be likely to be the demand the
global demand or even National demand
then how will this impact upon the
global price of natural gas
Mr Speaker we need to get on with the
exploration in the test drilling to see
how realistic the forecasts made
um by there's a report in 2012 that sets
out the potential for Shale gas which is
very large but the question he raises is
the right one how much of that will be
realistically extractable and that
requires drilling to take place to find
out Richard Holden and which indeed Mr
Speaker obviously in the long term
looking to these measures to increase
security and increase Supply is
incredibly sensible not only just in
terms of getting prices down but also in
terms of delivering energy security but
for many of my constituents still
struggling with Energy prices now
particularly those off grid can the
Secretary of State just outline a few of
those and weigh intends to go further in
that short-term support as well
Mr Speaker I think that was the last
urgent question that we discussed at so
I will ask the honorable gentleman to
look at Hansard
to rely Lucas
thank you Mr Speaker
thinks that he knows more about the
geology of the UK than the geologist who
founded quadrilla who said quite clearly
that the UK is unsuited to widespread
fracking but my question comes back to
this issue of consent the Prime Minister
did say that fracking will only go ahead
in places where there is support from
the local community which begs the
question about why on Earth he's even
pursuing this idea since there isn't any
support from local communities but how
is he going to measure that particularly
given that this terrible and deeply
unpopular decision coincides with the
government's Draconian new anti-protest
laws
in relation to quadrilla the gentleman
in question I believe left the company
10 years ago so he's somewhat out of
date in terms of the company in terms of
the company that he purports that he
purports to represent the um current the
current the current management of
quadrilla are in favor of this I I think
local support is important and one of
the things the companies who want to
drill for Shale gas will have to do
we'll come up with packages that are
attractive to local communities and that
I think ensures that people actually get
some Financial reward from Shell Gas
being extracted near them both families
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to press
my right honorable friend further on
this issue of how Community Support is
going to be defined and measured because
I have many concerned constituents who
want to know that they have a genuine
route to rejecting fracking applications
that don't have local support and I'm
still not clear what that would be
um Mr Speaker there are parts of the
country particularly in relation to
nuclear where local concerns and support
is very enthusiastic for um for the
development of additional energy sites
so it is perfectly possible to measure
and see local support Bill esterson the
homes of people living near to the alt
car Moss proposed tracking site shook as
a result of the tests that he referred
to earlier the Secretary of State said
Shale gas was safe but his government
paid compensation to residents living
near fracking sites in Lancashire this
government its own report says little
progress has been made in reducing and
predicting the risks when is he finally
going to admit that fracking is a
non-starter in this country
in relation to seismic activity there is
no particular dissimilarity with that
from Mining and that mining is not
subject to seismic limits so Greg knack
Mr Speaker despite what he said is it
not the case that forecasting the
occurrence of seismic events as a result
of fracking remains a challenge to The
Experts is it not therefore creating a
risk of an unknown quantity to pursue
Shale gas exploration at the present
time is he aware the safety of the
public is not a currency in which some
of us choose to speculate yeah yeah
foreign
[Applause]
I disagree with my uh right honorable
friend that it is all a matter of
proportionality and that as I pointed
out the um movement on the ground level
that we have from construction is more
than double that that is about double
that that we have had from any instance
with Shale gas so we know what has
happened before there are not limits um
on mining there are not limits on
ordinary oil extraction it is only Shale
gas that has these limits and there is
no evidence that Shale gas is worse than
any of these other activities so I think
on a balance of risks my right old
friend is not coming to the right
conclusion
[Music]
thank you very much Mr Speaker I I take
it a bit Rich from the self-style
minister for the 19th century that he
thinks the CEO of quadrilla is out of
date
his Manifesto said that we will not
support fracking unless the science
shows categorically that it can be done
safely the science has not proved
categorically that it can be done safely
so here's reneging on his solemn promise
which all of them stood on to the
British people in 2019 this is not a
legitimate thing for this government to
do is it yeah Mr Speaker we must
reiterate I must reiterate the the
former Chief Executive quadrilla
resigned 10 years ago he does not
represent the company and that is
important and the house would be put
under misapprehension if it were to
think that he were currently involved as
regards the last Manifesto I have listed
on the last Manifesto because I'd read
the 2012 report that went through most
of the myths against Shale gas and
showed that they were wrong and that the
extraction of shale gas is safe Scott
Benton Mr Speaker the secretary of state
will be aware of the strong objections
which many of my constitio Insurance
have to fracking the Prime Minister has
been quite clue in Senate will only take
place if there is strong local support
for it however this poses many questions
what is local community and how do you
define that how do you ascertain whether
or not it can command local support and
what incentives if any are going to be
provided to local communities to have
fracking imposed upon them my
constituents are understandably anxious
about fracking returning to the file
coast and so when will they receive an
answer to some of these questions thank
you Mr Speaker my humble friend asked a
very important question because it is
important for the national interest that
we have secure supplies of gas that is
something important across the house to
all constituents but this will affect
some residents much much more than
others and therefore it is only right
that they are compensated and that they
receive some Financial benefit it for
the inconvenience that they will have
now I would say to my honorable friend
that the majority of the inconvenience
does not actually come from the
extraction of shale gas but it comes
from the building of the Shale gas well
in the first place and the Lorry
movements that are associated with that
and it is important that people benefit
and are awarded for doing something that
is in the National interest Jeremy call
me
speaker what studies has the Secretary
of State taken of the effect on aquifers
where fracking has taken place that are
deeply polluted and run well beyond
the local community that is seeking the
support for to introduce fracking back
into this country surely he must
understand the dangers of this are going
to be here for decades and decades to
come long after whatever small amounts
of gas have been extracted and its
future Generations that will suffer
because of this policy
um Mr Speaker it's no surprise that I
disagree with the right honorable
gentleman
um that the I would refer him to the
2012 report that was done that went
through this and went through what had
happened in the United States for
comparison purposes first of all it
found that the evidence on pollution of
aquifers was not actually any good that
most of the stories were invented or
were scare stories but in addition to
that the UK has a very good regulatory
regime so the combination of ignoring
the scare stories and decent regulation
means that one can be confident that
Aquas will not be damaged it's Robert
Sims can I welcome this announcement
it's one of the few from the front bench
which actually will make us a lot richer
if we pursue this it'll also make us
more resilient in a very difficult world
but the key seems to me what advantage
those communities that may be affected
can get in terms of financial support
and has the secretary of state had any
discussions with the treasury because it
seems to me that if local people do give
good consent it's in the National
interest
I'm very grateful
um my honorable friend makes exactly the
right Point both ways round that this is
in the National interest will make the
country richer but it's absolutely right
that those affected should be rewarded
and to my mind that is direct Financial
reward and not a theoretical one the
last time we discussed fracking the idea
was that communities would be delighted
if they got 10 pounds for the Village
Hall I don't think that's the right way
to do it it needs to be direct to the
individuals who are affected and I've
had preliminary discussions with my
right-hand friend the chancellor but I
don't have a formal thing to announce
hello Morgan
thank you Mr Speaker residents in the
northern part of my constituency are
rightly concerned about the impact of
Tremors on their often older buildings
and they're worried about the impact of
the extraction of coal bed methane
through freckling on their rival way of
life
can the secretary Secretary of split
State explain in detail which he hasn't
done so far exactly the mechanism that
communities will be able to refuse to
allow their consent for cold bed
extraction and and Shell Gas fracking
because compensation is not consent yeah
yeah
well compensation and consent become two
sides of the same coin that people will
be able to negotiate the level of
compensation and it will be it will be a
matter for the companies to try and
ensure widespread consent by offering a
compensation package that is attractive
do you know Mr Speaker the other side
they howl and whale about this because
actually we're trying we're we're we're
trying to use we're driving you is
Market forces it's amazing a
conservative government using Market
forces Andrew bridgen figure does my
writable friend agree with me that we
should have been fracking our Shell Gas
two years ago but we are where we are
and then now the best available time to
start is immediately rubbish Mr Speaker
my uncle friend says only two years ago
why such a short time frame Stephanie
peacock thank you Mr Speaker the
government's own figures showing 70 of
the public support fracking 3 000 people
in Barnsley signed a petition against it
there is no local consent where I
represent and given the last round of
cracking licenses we're in Yorkshire how
will the Secretary of State ensure that
Northern Communities are not
disproportionately affected by this
outdated and dangerous way to create
energy
well it's definitely not outdated it's a
very effective and Modern Way of
extracting uh energy and what I would
say to people is do they want cheaper
and more secure energy or not and if the
answer is yes then fracking is going to
be part of the answer Jerome Mayu
Mika the secretary of state has made
repeated reference to a 2012 report
which identified considerable potential
reserves how significant might these be
in achieving uh energy security
I'm very grateful to my honorable friend
it is an important and fundamental
question the answer is that we need to
do the um test drilling first to see
whether these reserves can be achieved
in the way that the 2012 report hoped
but I can't give a firm commitment on
that because we haven't done enough test
drilling yet
thank you Mr Speaker coming back to 2019
Tony party Manifesto which each member
opposite stood on yeah it's the same
order to remove fracking would only be
lifted and I quote from page 55.
early sign says it shows it can be done
safely a change in Tory party leadership
is not a change in scientific evidence
can the Secretary of State Enlighten the
house as to why the government thinks
they are both above logic and above
science
because all the evidence is that it can
be done safely as it is in the United
States and as the 2012 report that I've
referred to many times indicated
Mr Speaker I've been quite shocked
actually by the luddites on the front
bench who have been quite open in saying
that they're going to weaponize this in
a general election so for those who fear
the unknown may I tell my right
honorable friend that the 0.5 limit on
the wrist of scale is nothing compared
to the 1.5 limit on the Richter Scale
which Litchfield is currently enduring
from pile driving for hs2 if we can live
with that though we don't really like
living with that Mr Speaker we can
certainly enjoy the benefits from
fracking
Mr Speaker
um my honorable friend makes an
absolutely right and wise point that the
motto of honorable right honorable
members opposite for the next election
is let's be cold and poor that's really
the prospectus they're putting before
the British Country British people and
as regard seismic activity there are
millions of seismic events of 2.5 or
lower in the world every year we should
not assume that every seismic event is
the San Francisco earthquake
Mr Speaker lifting the ban on lifting
the cap on Bankers bonuses whilst at the
same time making it harder for working
people to access benefits now lifting
the safety limits on seismic events or
earthquakes to you and me whilst at the
same time protecting indeed subsidizing
oil companies excessive profits as well
as accelerating climate change doesn't
this decision really show whose side the
story government is on
his Majesty's government is on the side
of people who need energy and a business
that needs energy and of an economy that
needs to grow the party opposite are in
favor of no growth coldness and high
prices
to Costa Coffee in like uh on Tuesday
Morning rivaled the House of Commons
chamber this morning for the robustness
of debate the sense of opinions
expressed I sought to be a sure
constituents that they would have the
opportunity to have their say because
the local consent was required listening
carefully to the Integrity stage this
morning have yet to hear any explanation
of how a local consent will be
determined indeed and absent of any
reference to local consent but then we
try once more will my constituent to be
asked whether they want fracking or not
Mr Speaker as I've said in the Prime
Minister said we will be looking to have
the support of local communities that is
important and there will be a
responsibility for the companies when
they bring forward proposals to work out
how they can get that local consent and
it seems to be pretty clear that that
will involve giving money to people to
encourage them and because they will
want to have the benefit locally whilst
they are doing something that helps the
country nationally oh Williams
thank you Mr Speaker in Wales we know
the cost of dangerous fossil fuel
extraction so that others remotely can
profits it's particularly huge today the
dates of the Crestwood mining disaster
where 266 men and boys were killed
200 women who widowed 800 children were
left fatherless
the coal mine owned by the Westminster
and the United group who subsequently
destroyed the safety records
Mr Speaker Crestwood was mooted as a
fracking site and there the man killed
remained by the way two thousand feet
down only 11 bodies were recovered that
smuted as a fracking site
so will the executive States confirm
that he understands that powers on
fracking remain with our Senate and that
he has no intention of trying to return
those powers to Westminster
Mr Speaker I'm not seeking to upset the
Devolution settlement
Mr Speaker even before a Putin's illegal
war in Ukraine fracking had advantages
because of the benefit for jobs
investment tax revenues and the balance
of payments positivity which I'd rather
was accruing here in the UK rather than
sending tens of billions to Qatar in
other places now is is my right or
friend aware of the CO2 Savings of
domestic energy supplier it has been
calculated that there are five million
tons of CO2 emitted just for the LNG
process of of calling decasification and
also the transport that has got to be a
moral outrage
Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
absolutely right that he takes his
argument through logically unlike many
people on the benches opposite that if
we wish if we wish to reduce carbon
emissions we are better off using gas as
a transition fuel that comes from our
own resources rather than importing it
that must be true and we have those
resources we need the transition fuel
therefore we should try and extract it
domestically John Trick it
Mr Speaker and today's uh panicky
trumpian announcement
is is brought about because of the
failure of successive Tory governments
who squandered the opportunity which
coal oil and gas our indigenous
resources offered to transfer transform
our economy into a carbon-free economy
will the Minnesota state now confirm
that on his Target list for fracking uh
those areas in the north and Yorkshire
which are often described as red wall
and kind of finally bring this point to
him there is no local consent in those
areas at all for what he's proposing
this morning
well Mr Speaker it will be important for
the companies that wish to extract gas
to ensure that there is local support
and to come up with packages that make
sure that that is forthcoming it is
important that local communities welcome
the extraction of shale gas and I think
it's very likely that they will
sleeping trap thank you Mr Speaker faced
for the Russian leader who uses gas
supply as a tool of warfare it is
entirely prudent to examine again the
viability of all of our domestic energy
resources but can I really encourage my
right Uncle Fred not to lose sight of
some of the other big exciting potential
opportunities opening up for example
floating offshore wind power in the
Celtic Sea and would he meet with myself
and other colleagues with an interest in
the Celtic Sea to discuss what further
steps he and his Department can take to
further those projects oh I'd be
absolutely delighted to meet my
right-home friend to discuss this it is
something that um the department is
looking at we are really enthusiastic
about examining all sources I think
floating offshore wind is potentially a
very good one we want to see if we can
expedite offshore wind projects so that
they happen faster and we get the
supplies coming in we need to be looking
and we are looking and we're in
discussions with other countries about
how we can expedite carbon capture and
storage and moving towards hydrogen that
the long-term issues are ones we are
focusing on and dealing with but we have
many years of needing gas and it's why I
welcome so much am I right honorable
friends support for this announcement
I'm Russell Moore
speaker it was this government that has
made onshore wind less economical it is
this government that has made solar
power and panels less economical it is
this government that blocked wave and
tidal power in the Swansea Bay it is
this government that has failed to
invest and now they are trying to cover
it up with a fracking giveaway that
there will never be any local consent
for will the minister and he's been
asked numerous times confirm that the
people in local areas will get a say
through a local referendum and it will
be binding yeah Mr Speaker this
government's enemy in office for about a
fortnight and now I know it's been busy
I've been busy it hasn't quite managed
to do everything that The Honorable
gentleman that The Honorable gentleman
suggests as regards local consent I
refer The Honorable gentleman to the
answer I gave some moments ago
Fletcher speaker I've listened carefully
to the Secretary of State and I have to
say the local consent plans don't seem
to wash it seems to come back to
communities being bought off rather than
having a vote so can the Secretary of
State confirm once and for all if local
residents across bolsover who are
concerned about fracking will get a vote
to object to these schemes locally
Mr Speaker I think I made it very clear
that um the companies will have a deep
responsibility to develop packages that
make the extraction of shale gas
attractive to local communities it is
really important that they succeed
within in that just it matters
you Mr Speaker I think people have
elsewhere he's signaled their opposition
to fracking the planning application was
submitted a number of years ago the
local Authority rejected it there was an
appeal many local residents gave
evidence against the application after
three years it was finally decided that
it would not be accepted
today Chester Zoo big employment
constituency has stated that they're
opposed to fracking many constituents
are repeating their objection so there
is no local consent you know some
important neston so can the Secretary of
State send a message back to the
fracking companies that there's no point
in coming to ask because they will not
get our agreement
Mr Speaker
um asking which will be given so you can
use shall find it is absolutely
important that we try and get local
consent and that will require the
drilling companies to be Innovative in
the packages they come up with and we
shouldn't be ashamed of paying people
who are going to be the ones who don't
get the immediate benefit of the gas but
have the disruption that is a perfectly
logical thing to do at the beginning
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker can I can I just
also ask once again how this secretary
of state will measure local consent
because I have absolutely no confidence
in labor run kirkles listening to local
wishes they they don't even they don't
even distribute the section 106 payments
from planning applications to local
communities fairly how would we ensure
that those impacted by any fracking
Wells get any benefit from it and my
honorable friend hits the nail on the
head it is fundamentally important that
the cash benefits do not go to some
faceless bureaucracy but they give the
individuals who are affected actually in
the United States this has made the
extraction of shalegasm enormously
popular because people are quite like
improving their standard of living and I
think the same is true in this country
thank you Mr Speaker can the Secretary
of State explain exactly how the UK
government deciding to get rid of the
fracking ban aligns with their cop 26
commitments
Mr Speaker using our domestic resources
as my honorable friend uh mentioned
earlier reduces our carbon emissions
it's really straightforward Keely
I think he's an outdated dangerous and
expensive way to produce energy that
will not provide the clean secure energy
our country needs in my constituency
exploratory fracking site at Barton Moss
needed a police operation which cost
greater Manchester police 1.7 million
pounds in 2014 involved 150 police
officers across five months fracking did
not have community support and greater
Manchester police had to pay the heavy
price of policing the demonstrations
against it why is the government forcing
this back on the community in my
constituency yeah Mr Speaker there's a
war in Ukraine we need security of
Supply Martin Docker to use
I wonder if the Secretary of State can
advise the house what discussions will
take place between his department and
the Scotland office in enabling fracking
in Scotland
Mr Speaker I regularly have
conversations with the Secretary of
State for Scotland
Thursday Murray Gardner
this cannot be justified on
environmental grounds and it cannot be
justified on economic grounds the
investment allowance will give gas
producers 91 pence in every pound
invested in new frat pads now Warwick
Business School calculates that fracking
could produce 330 billion cubic meters
at a maxim about 100 billion thirds at
today's spot price about 20 minutes ago
that would be 289 billion pounds given
that the taxpayers are covering nine
tenths of the investment why should they
not get nine tenths of the profit
Mr Speaker
The Honorable gentleman is making the
argument for fracking if there is that
amount that we can get out we should get
it out as quickly as possible and then
we should ensure that it is distributed
properly so that the people who are
affected benefit so that the companies
who have invested benefit and yes so
that the taxpayer benefits because the
oil and gas we get out of the North Sea
has been an enormous benefit to the
taxpayer and has helped us have energy
security so it is a beneficial thing to
do and as regards the economics the
economics is straightforward private
companies will not invest if it's not a
good deal that's the basis of economics
and it's the right basis of Economics
Simon live Mr Speaker I don't know about
you but I'm sensing some Tremors of
dissent on the ventures opposite
fracking is expensive and dangerous but
it's also a disaster for our climate
does the Secretary of State recognize
that if every country matched his plans
to extract every ounce of gas the planet
would warm by three degrees spelling
climate disaster does he not understand
that this is a plan but of climate
denial and economic illiteracy
um Mr Speaker
this is an alternative replacement
source for gas that we are going to use
anyway it is not increasing our demand
for gas and The Honorable gentleman
misses the ABC of economics
Mick Whitley
yesterday thank you Mr Speaker yesterday
the business secretary confirmed that
his departments will be reviewing the
level of seismic activity thus permitted
to take place and new flocking
installations meanwhile the government's
energy security strategy pointed rules
outlifting the Draconian planning
restrictions that would impose an unsure
win by the Cameron governments I'm sure
wind is one of the cheapest most popular
and fastest to roll out forms of energy
production available to us meanwhile
fracking as the chancellor themselves
have said it's usually costly with
little to reduce domestic energy costs
and risks inflate inflicting immense
damage on local communities and our
precious natural environments will the
second city states can see concede that
the governments has got its priorities
wrong
Mr Speaker the thing we are lacking at
the moment most acutely is affordable
gas and gas is the fuel that provides
electricity at the margin so when the
wind isn't blowing
um and when demand is high it is gas
that provides the marginal unit of
electricity it is therefore
fundamentally important to our energy
security
speaker the now Chancellor said only a
few months ago that no amount of chair
glass gas explored across rural England
would lower energy prices and indeed
that private companies would not um sell
their shell gas to UK customers at a
lower than the market price so Mr
Speaker ruining our Countryside in
Sussex in in East Surrey in around bath
actually it's not the answer
so
why Renewables is why has he in his
first week of office ended the
moratorium on fracking but not lifted
the de facto moratorium on onshore wind
um Mr Speaker we need to get as much
energy as possible and fracking does not
ruin the countryside fracking sites are
actually surprisingly surprisingly small
for what they actually do
um no we have been expanding offshore
wind very dramatically that has been a
very big component and we are continuing
with increasing Renewables but we still
need that base Supply that can be
brought on when there is a surge in
demand and that is dependent on gas that
Western thank you Mr Speaker
um the public will see this as a deceit
because there's no economical price
advantages we've heard to this whilst so
damaging the environment the claim that
the public will actually have some say
in the consent of this will ring Hollow
to my community where the district
council opposed a 5G Mast but it was
over ridden so can he explain why he
thinks that there is any advantage in
this when we can't even put an onshore
wind in Warwickshire it's the only
County I believe in this country where
there is no onshore wind
energy Security in price
currents
the right honorable Secretary of State's
constituency Northeast Somerset borders
mine in Bristol South it'd be helpful if
you can confirm that we're not expecting
any fracking in the local community or
any seismic events equally in Bristol
South smaller medium-sized businesses
were Innovative about green and future
energy they had the legs cut from
underneath them in 2015 when his
government cut the green crap what
Assurance can he give businesses in
Bristol sell for future energy
development
Mr Speaker the subsidies that are paid
when they are paid have to be reasonable
and proportionate and that we're finding
that with some of the old contracts that
we have based on the uh gasp on the gas
price for renewable energy which has led
to very high prices that Northeast
Somerset was the site of the old
Somerset coldfields which were a very
successful part of the economy
historically and I think everyone in
this country will have to do their bit
to help with energy security
I wanted the Secretary of State could
placate the luddites and publish the
up-to-date evidence that enabled the
government to U-turn both on the
manifesto commitments and the previous
prime minister's policy
Mr Speaker I believe this is completely
consistent with the manifesto commitment
on the safety of of shale gas the issue
that the reason why it has come to the
for now is because of the very high
price increase in gas and the issue of
energy security caused by Putin's
invasion of Russia and that is something
that has fundamentally changed and so on
the balance of arguments and
practicalities with a safe and
well-proved Technology it is right now
to extract Shale gas as far as we can
damn near Griffith thank you very much
indeed uh Mr Speaker well as the
government security strategy in 2022
acknowledges onshore wind is one of the
cheapest and easiest Renewables to bring
on stream but that same strategy is
wishy-washy and likes any drive for fast
tracking of new wind generation so will
the Secretary of State now recognize the
urgency of the current situation revise
the strategy give onshore wind in
England the Boost it needs to complement
the investment in wind that Welsh labor
has continued to promote in Wales and
therefore be able to reduce our Reliance
the proportion being some 47 currently
of electricity that is produced from gas
Mr Speaker what we do with Renewables is
still going to leave us dependent when
the wind is not blowing and when there
is a surge in demand on on gas and that
is an important part of the strategy so
we are building our we are building our
our wind supplies we are building up our
nuclear supplies we have plans for more
nuclear to come on there's an important
part of it but for the transition we
still need gas which is what this
announcement is about Catherine West
that when a party stands on a Manifesto
promise regardless of what it is that it
sticks by that and that can he rule out
today that this announcement that this
proposal is not linked to any donations
which were made during the leadership
election
thank you Mr speaker
thank you Mr Speaker fracking takes huge
amounts of water we have just seen
record levels of drought across the
entire country with drier Summers
predicted for the future so in periods
of drought will Tory ministers be
prioritizing precious Water Supplies to
people in their homes or to Big fracking
companies
the the water for fracking is primarily
recycled Richard Bergen
the Secretary of State talks about
fracking being in the National interest
the truth is that fracking is in the
corporate interest and that's why this
government's pursuing it this is going
to do nothing to lower People's Energy
bills Renewables and nine times cheaper
than gas so at the time that we should
be moving away from an ending Reliance
upon gas isn't this push really about
serving the intro tests of those energy
Giants many of which have close links to
his party and isn't it about time they
acted in the interests of the people in
Yorkshire and across this country
Mr Speaker what is the honorable
gentleman gave say to his constituents
when there is no gas going to their
boilers to heat their hot water and to
heat their homes there's ridiculous
hostility to gas as a transition fuel is
absurd
you Mr Speaker onshore wind power if it
was effectively stopped by the Secretary
of State's government yet it's proven in
the UK it's cheap it's ready to go now
and provides zero carbon power
everything that fracking doesn't so will
the threshold for community support for
fracking be as tough as that for onshore
wind development where wonder One
objector can stop it
Mr Speaker regardless of the benefits of
Renewables we still need gas which is
what today's statement is about I bet
um the secretary's admitted the
environmental impact of fracking the
drilling platforms the wells and the
Lorry movements which are significant to
substantial
the planning system is best place to
deal with these so in 2018 the select
committee did a report on planning
guidance on fracking where we concluded
that fracking decisions were best made
by elected local planning authorities
we don't know what the government's view
is because four years later after that
report we still haven't had a response
from ministers to the recommendations we
made
can I say to the Secretary of State will
he give an assurance that by the end of
October when we come back the government
will have responded four years late to
the report we did
[Music]
speaker the Lord president of the
council and leader of the house is
present and I think that's very much a
business question
um I would say I'll make sure it's
passed on to her but I hope that she
will feel it has been passed on anyway
Peter Grant thank you Mr Speaker
listening to members on both sides of
the house very gradually teasing out for
the Secretary State really meant when he
said that compensation and consent are
two sides of the same coin why doesn't
it just come clean and say as tell as it
is that the government intends to change
the payment of bribes for planning
consent from a criminal offense to the
official policy of his Majesty's
government
[Music]
Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman is a
wise and good man
um but that point is is is completely
fatuous uh that paying people for
inconvenience is a perfectly reasonable
and Commercial thing to do
thank you Mr Speaker the truth is this
won't provide any immediate relief for
consumers and when in Wales we've taken
measures to try and support our energy
security it was the UK government that
pulled the rug out under tidal power and
tidal lagoons and has failed to make
progress on wilvenoweth now will he be
absolutely clear the Welsh government
has issued a moratorium on fracking it's
very clear 1900 submissions to
consultation will he absolutely rule out
attempting to undermine that position
and that consent that view from the
Welsh government
Mr Speaker there's no plan to change the
divulge situation and I've said that
already before and it's not a matter for
my department anyway so I can give him
uh that Assurance as regard tidal power
the costing simply weren't uh economic
and that has been a problem with tidal
proposals named
the secretary of state has talked a lot
about common sense and about using our
natural resources so can you just
explain to me why it is the government
are not dropping the moratorium on
offshore onshore wind but
um Mr Speaker we have had an enormous
amount of offshore Wind come on and that
is a very important part of of
Renewables and has been a very effective
way of getting very large quantities of
of power and that has been the major
concentration of government policy in
recent years Jeff Smith
speaker who specifically will be
responsible for measuring and
determining local consent for fracking
Mr Speaker it will be a matter that will
be dealt with in a governmental way as
is normally done it when you are seeking
to work out what what consents are there
are perfectly proper processes for
establishing the views of local
communities true Andre
speaker fracking is the most unpopular
and least effective way of producing
energy and risks substantial geological
impacts and yet there is no evidence
that it will reduce the price of gas
according to the government's own
advisors unsure when solar and hydro
including pump storage new Cutting Edge
Technologies are all much much cheaper
and much much safer and popular why does
he dislike these Technologies so much
and whose interests are being furthered
by fracking and Mr Speaker The Honorable
gentleman's wrong to say I dislike those
Technologies I actually think pumped
Hydro is a particularly interesting
technology because it can be used with
wind power to um acts effectively as a
battery so there is support for these
and we are discussing under this urgent
question today Mr Speaker Shale gas that
doesn't mean
um that my department is not looking at
all forms of energy we need a wide range
of supply and we need security of supply
and we need to have cheap Supply or as
cheap as we can get it Matt rodder
Mr Speaker residents across the south of
England are deeply concerned about the
risks of fracking and indeed oil
drilling why is the sector State not
listening to those concerns and why is
he also not listening to the concerns of
the government's former Chief Scientific
Advisor and indeed those of the British
Geological Survey
um Mr Speaker quite properly the
concerns of this house are being
represented by members of parliament so
they are being listened to By Her
Majesty's government cat Smith yeah
it is the early person who believes that
fracking will lower our gas prices is
the Secretary of State it's certainly
not backed up by anyone in industry and
there's no question over the
environmentally damaging nature of
fracking but one thing I think this
exercise is perhaps not aware of is the
strength of opposition to fracking in
communities like mine in Lancashire
where sites at Preston new road and
rosica have seen a huge police presence
just to manage the protesting and there
is no public support for fracking so I'd
like to ask the Secretary of State if he
can be very clear to my constituents in
Lancaster and Fleetwood whether or not
they will be given
decision on whether or not fracking
happens in Lancashire let's speak a
number of people have said that fracking
is environmentally unfriendly it is more
friendly than importing LNG from abroad
it is a lower carbon footprint and this
is fundamentally uh important and I'm
well aware that there have been
objections to fracking but I would also
note that there have been stories widely
reported that some of the opposition to
be fracking has been funded by Mr
Putin's regime
thank you Mr Speaker and does the
Secretary of State recognize that he has
now put his government in the Absurd
position of wanting to impose fracking
on communities that don't want it whilst
not allowing onshore wind turbines where
communities do want it onshore wind
turbines are cheap they are quick to
erect and they normally bring about
cheaper energy bills for local
communities so will he please at last
without reference to Offshore wind and
everything else that he's doing will he
please answer the question directly will
he lift the ban on onshore wind
communicate to consent is important and
The Honorable lady is right to point
that out five effort speaker but then
only a few weeks ago the Prime Minister
quoted the conservative Manifesto when
she said she was going to reverse
National Insurance because they have
pledged not to increase it so apparently
that was a solemn pledge but the
manifesto also said there will be no
fracking where there was no local
consent apparently not a a pledge so
kind of can this Secretary of State tell
us
will local communities be consulted
before testing takes place and who's
going to pay the bribes will it be the
taxpayer or as he says the market forces
Mr Speaker the Socialists don't like
being people being paid for things it
seems to be reasonable to pay people and
if you inconvenience them you compensate
them and that will be part of the
overall package if Shale gas can be
extracted
you Mr Speaker is the government aware
that Franklin is not only a broken
promise to the public by the
conservative party's 2019 Manifesto but
it will not cut bills it is a grossly
unpopular method and a method that will
warm our planet it is indeed wrapped up
in climate denial
it's actually none of those things where
is Sherman
thank you Mr Speaker can I say to the
minister that I've been listening very
carefully to his plea for good Common
Sense I've always believed good public
policy is made on good research and
evidence of what works where nothing he
said today indeed he don't know front
Pence has mentioned energy from waste
energy from waste Works successfully up
and down our country in Sheffield in
Leeds in Southampton in London and it
not only produces any good energy from
waste it also Heats many many homes in
the community at low cost what is the
government going to actually look at
that and stop diverting attention to
fracking
Mr Speaker I'm generally grateful to the
uh honorable gentleman that that's a
very important point we do actually
export waste I think to Denmark for the
Danes to turn it into energy it seems to
me it might be better to do it
domestically I think he's made a very
helpful suggestion
um I have already talked about it in the
Fortnight I've been in office and if he
wanted to make further representations
to me on it I'd be very open to hearing
them Patricia Gibson Mr Speaker can the
Secretary of State reassure me and my
constituents in North Ayrshire and Aaron
that the pre that the pernicious and
Insidious internal Market bill or any
other Sinister mechanism will not under
any circumstances be used to impose
fracking in Scotland against the express
wishes of the people of Scotland and
Scotland's democratically elected
government here here Mr Speaker the UK
internal markets Act is like the coin or
Diamond it is one of the jewels of our
constitutional settlement Margaret
Greenberg
thank you Mr Speaker
um my constituents will be extremely
alarmed to hear The Minister's remarks
about the exploitation of dangerous
fossil fuels they have made it
abundantly clear to me that they care
about the environment they care about
the Next Generation they take climate
change seriously so I ask him on behalf
of my constituents will he think again
and ban fracking yeah Mr Speaker The
Honorable lady refers to dangerous
fossil fuels that people depend on for
heating their water and heating their
homes every day that businesses depend
on for being in business the people put
in their cars to get around the
countryside we need to ensure that we
have a sensible transition gas is
fundamental to that simply wishing the
world to be a different world will not
be a successful policy Rachel maskel Mr
Speaker Yorkshire is currently under a
hose pipe band because we simply do not
have the infrastructure in place to
provide the resilience for our water and
of course at the same time when fracking
uses you know endorsement amounts of
water this proposal does not make sense
so will he publish an impact assessment
about our water infrastructure to ensure
that there is resilience in the system
before he even considers fracking
and The Honorable lady raises a very
fair point and it does depend on the
water company in my area Wessex water
have done a phenomenal job of ensuring
that they didn't need hose pipe bands or
get close to hose pipe bands because
they run their system effectively and I
think the honorable lady is right to
call upon the water companies to run
their systems effectively because it's
hard to believe that the United Kingdom
is actually short of water Andrew Gwen
secretary of state is well aware of the
strength of feeling against fracking in
those communities that are likely to
have the applications made by the
companies he's also aware of how the
planning system works he talks about
having common consent of the community
if the local Authority listens to the
community and refuses planning
permission the fracking companies have
the option of appealing to the planning
inspectorate
is not within the remit of the planning
inspectors to take into consideration
common consent as a material planning
consideration will he change the
planning rules to ensure that's not the
case yeah Mr Speaker The Honorable
gentleman will know that decisions on
planning when reviewed by the planning
inspector are made by a secretary of
state acting in a quasi-judicial
capacity
David London very much Mr Speaker if the
Prime Minister believes that fracking is
so safe and should go ahead with the
permission of local residents can I ask
by which date we can expect to see
fracking take place in the sprawling
country Retreat of czechos to the Prime
Minister ah
Mr Speaker I'm not sure that
geologically speaking Checkers is a
suitable place for Shale gas I I I think
the question
um uh from The Honorable lady the member
for Bristol South
um was actually more opposite because it
may be more likely in my part of the
world than in my right honorable friends
Jamie Stone thank you Mr Speaker
a few minutes ago the Secretary of State
uh mentioned hydrogen and hydrogen of
course is the perfect answer because
when you burn it you get water it's
totally green and totally clean Mr
Speaker there are well developed plans
for production storage of hydrogen based
on the committee first can I call the
invite either the secretary said at one
of his ministerial team to come north to
my constituency to see what we're going
to do yeah yeah Mr Speaker I could not
agree with the honorable gentleman mall
I think hydrogen is ultimately the
Silver Bullet I can see how you create
it from renewable sources because you
have the wind power when people are not
drawing on the electricity system you
use it as an effective battery and it
then can be with some adjustments pipe
through to people's houses to heat them
during the winter there are real
opportunities with hydrogen and we get
some heckling from the Socialist front
bench and I would point out to them that
everyone accepts that gas is a
transition fuel so to get to where the
honorable gentleman wisely wishes us to
go we need more natural gas as the
transition fuel but the honorable
gentleman is right and I would be I
don't know that I can promise a visit in
the short term but I'd love to come in
principle and my ministers are like like
the Greyhounds and the slips waiting to
get up to his constituency that's it
really
Glasgow and arts don't want to see
fracking anywhere on these islands so
ending what was in effect a uk-wide
moratorium and fracking doesn't exactly
speak to strengthening the union but
what my conceptions would like to know
is whether the business secretary
actually believes that we Face an
anthropogenic a climate emergency and if
so how on Earth I rush to fracking
Source fossil fuels helps to meet the
climate and emission reduction targets
we committed to yeah as my honorable
friend the member for thanet pointed out
using our own resources amidst less
carbon than importing gas so therefore
if the honorable gentleman actually
believes what he has just said he should
be supporting this policy
the spotlight upon energy crises upon
the Ukraine's uh war that that kitten is
carrying out against them
the others have referred it and what the
answer says to this question in relation
to those who live close by who will have
their houses they valued will have an
impact upon their lifestyle the second
status refer to compensation no
quantifying of the conversation has been
made can I ask a second to say this
question will the conversation be a
one-off payment for the value of their
house will it be no energy costs will it
be no rates what does the center State
understand that the compensation will be
is
as always The Honorable gentleman Waits
patiently to ask a fundamentally
important question and I'm very grateful
to him and as always for his assiduous
attendance in in the house
um how the compensation packages will be
worked up seems to me to be something
that will be really important to gaining
communities consent and there will be
different approaches that work in
different areas and different settings
but they need to be the right approach
to obtain the consent so
um this is something that must be
developed and The Honorable gentleman's
views on how it could best be developed
will be extremely welcome
I thank thee at Secretary of State uh
business questions shadow shadow lead
with the house thank him and debonair
thank you madam Deputy speaker to ask
the leader of the house that she will
give us the forthcoming business
Madam Deputy speaker before I give the
business I hope you will permit me to
place on record my admiration and thanks
for all those who enabled the morning of
her late Majesty to be so Exquisite
including the actions of the general
public it was done so well it was done
with much love we did her proud
subject to The house's agreement of the
motion on today's order paper the
business for Friday the 23rd of
September will be the chancellor the
exchequer will make a statement on the
government's plans for growth
subject to The house's agreement the
house will then rise for the conference
recess and return on Tuesday the 11th of
October
the business for the week commencing the
10th of October will include Tuesday the
11th of October consideration of an
allocation of time motion followed by
all stages of the Health and Social care
Levy repeal Bill Wednesday the 12th of
October second reading of the identity
and language Northern Ireland Bill Lords
followed by a motion relating to the
procedure committee's recommendations
relating to proxy voting Thursday the
13th of October second reading of the
economic crime and corporate
transparency Bill Friday the 14th of
October the house will not be sitting
the provisional business for the week
commencing the 17th of October includes
Monday the 17th of October remaining
stages of the public order bill
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
thank the leader of the House for the
forthcoming business and I would also
like to join her in commending the house
and member staff as well as members
across this place who work so hard both
with the laying in States and the
tributes to the late Queen I also agree
I think we did her majesty proud and it
was an honor for to close the debates
the tributes uh with the right honorable
lady may also commend her for the
impeccable way in which she took up her
role as law president so swiftly and
becoming the first woman to proclaim a
mnemonic and do so with great Poise
Madam Deputy speaker I welcome the
leaders response to my question two
weeks ago about the appointment of a new
government ethics advisor and the leader
said then the Prime Minister would get
around to it swiftly well at least
they're planning to appoint one the
government has been missing one for
months now so where's the urgency could
the leader tell us exactly where this
ranks on the prime minister's to-do list
because madam Deputy speaker an Ethics
advisor could have offered guidance to
the cabinet office who see who seem to
think it's appropriate to assist the
right honorable member for Uxbridge and
South reislip by commissioning legal
advice on his behalf does the leader
think that this what looks like
interference with the house privileges
committee inquiry was appropriate does
she expect the member in question to
repay any money that was spent by
taxpayers
on legislation about a deputy speaker I
don't see any listing in the statement
for legislation on the energy bills
crisis and there doesn't seem to be an
actual bill yet so can I ask if there's
going to be legislation when we will see
it and when we will actually debate and
vote on it and on legislation that the
government seems to be planning to bin
in their bonfire of bills the Prime
Minister indicated the Bill of Rights
and the Animal Welfare bill will be
scrapped and the SEC business secretary
is apparently also told officials to
stop work on the energy bill is there
some clarity we could have here could
the leader confirm if the government is
planning to drop these bills
and while we're on broken Manifesto
promises we are now told that there is
no chance of a trade deal with the us
anytime soon despite it being a number
one priority in 2019 then a deadline of
mid-21 an apparent significant progress
last summer and I do wonder who it was
who was the trade secretary and then the
foreign secretary who seemed to have
messed this up so badly
I do also wish to ask about the swerving
of scrutiny the government yesterday the
business sector yesterday announced the
fuel Bill relief scheme before coming to
this house which Mr Speaker had
specifically asked the new prime
minister to not do as previous Prime
Ministers had and ministers now instead
of voluntary providing a ministerial
statement today he's had to be dragged
to the parliament to Parliament to face
Christians could the leader have a word
with him please
the leader also announced that the
chancellor will make a statement
tomorrow a so-called mini budget yet
members will only have what looks like a
few hours to scrutinize it and there is
no accompanying briefings from the
office of budget responsibility just
changing the name doesn't really change
what it is or the need for those
economic briefings I have to ask what is
it the government is seeking to hide can
she answer why we're only getting half a
day and why will there actually in fact
be any economic forecast made tomorrow
Mr Madam Deputy speaker
at the end of the day politics is about
choices this prime minister is choosing
to lift the cap on investment bankers
bonuses over putting money back into
working people's pockets she is choosing
to back the fossil fuel Lobby by lifting
the ban on fracking over investing in
renewable energy she's choosing to make
the British people pay for her energy
policy with debt piling up into the
future Labor's plan to make sure people
don't have to pay a penny more this
winter would have been funded by a
windfall tax on oil and gas company's
windfall profits when it comes to
choices the Tories are choosing to side
with bankers and oil and gas giants
while labor is choosing to side with
everybody else thank you madam Deputy
speaker
have well can I start by thanking the uh
honorable lady for her very kind remarks
um it was a privilege to do the
accession council
um the government has set out very
clearly what its immediate priorities
are the Prime Minister will get to uh
the matter of an Ethics advisor but her
priorities as she has stated have been
ensuring that people in this country can
see a doctor and a dentist it has been
and you won't have to wait very long to
hear from the Deputy Prime Minister and
Secretary of State for health on that
matter it is about getting growth back
into our economy and building a modern
economy through supply side reform again
the house will not have long to wait to
hear about that plan directly from the
chancellor and can question him on the
legislative program that will follow and
clearly dealing with the cost of living
issues which are of major concern to
both household and businesses and we
have had clearly uh the Secretary of
State for bases time this morning in
talking through his proposals those are
the government's priorities we are
acting on those it was clearly right
that we observed a period of mourning
for her late Majesty but this week is
the first opportunity we've had to bring
these measures forward and present them
to the house and we are doing so that
those are the Prime Minister and her
government's priorities
um she raises the issue of the trade a
trade deal with the United States there
is good news and there is bad news uh
clearly we would have wanted a a tariff
Arrangement uh faster than the US is
prepared to move but we will continue to
press them on that the opposition can
help us in that by outlining why this is
a good idea for both the UK and the
United States to their friends in the
Democratic party but we have not been
idle in the meantime she will know that
we have been pursuing state level
Arrangements on non-tariff barriers to
trade removing those we've signed two
with a further 25 States interested and
the first eight we sign will be
equivalent to 20 of the US economy so
that is the bad news the good news is at
long last the labor party are supportive
of a trade deal the United States and
I'm delighted to uh hear that because
with regard to handling of business it
is incredibly important that these the
house here's uh things first uh we want
to ensure that the time has the house
has the time it needs both to question
ministers in statements but also time to
scrutinize legislation A wise man once
said it is a fundamental constitutional
right that this house should be told
things first uh that is the former
leader of the house and the Secretary of
State for Bayes and I will hold him to
it we have some major challenges uh
facing this country because of the war
in Ukraine an incredibly volatile
economy and I do hope that we can uh
take the the mood of unity and
cooperation that has been the flavor of
this house in recent days and apply them
to these problems together for the
benefit of all the people we serve
to John Redwood
will the government allow us an early
debate on its growth strategy which will
be most welcome so that Parliament can
have an opportunity to put forward good
ideas on obstacles and barriers to
better paid jobs and more investment
which still exist under our current
panoply of law
for raising these issues clearly the
chancellor will be making a statement
tomorrow but he will know how to apply
for a debate on all these issues and it
is very important that we are Consulting
and listening to businesses and our
constituents uh they're the best ideas
governments have come from people who
are doing those jobs who are taking
those risks and wanting to put growth
back into our economy SMP spokesperson
Deidre Brock thank you madam Deputy
speaker and I thank the leader for her
statement I too want to pay tribute on
behalf of my SNP colleagues and myself
to the staff of these houses of
Parliament for their exceptional work in
preparing and carrying out the various
ceremonies and duties required after the
sad passing of Queen Elizabeth they were
outstanding
um Madam Deputy speaker I welcome very
much the content of the statutory
instruments being debated this afternoon
tightening the sanctions against Putin
and his supporters uh particularly after
his recent threats I see recently though
that U.S intelligence estimates over 300
million dollars of Russian money has
been plowed into influencing politicians
in more than 24 countries now it
suggested this is just the tip of the
iceberg so can we have a debate in
government time about swatting possible
Russian influence on UK politics to
reassure the public isn't it
extraordinary though Madam Deputy
speaker that despite only sitting a
handful of times since the end of July
and our constituents facing the biggest
cost of living crisis in decades members
are about to trot off for conference
recess rather than debating these
problems fully here and now and we can
at least expect a short fiscal statement
before then elements of which have been
trailed in the media this government
displaying its customary almost casual
disrespect for this place so we've seen
some of the rabbits the chancellor
likely intends pulling out of his hat on
Friday but so far they look awfully like
leftovers from the discredited
trickle-down economics Theory so beloved
of the right wing but which as President
Biden himself pointed out recently has
never worked I here too the government
is lodging its revocation and Reform
Bill or as it was formerly known the
comically named brexit Freedom's bill
today and I say comical but the prospect
of this house and the devolved
parliaments being bogged down again in
for many months in secondary legislation
as the zealots on government benches try
to extinguish every trace of the EU from
UK legislation threatening protections
for workers rights and food standards
amongst so many others is far from funny
can we intentionally indicate when we'll
have that come to the house for debate
and finally it is no wonder Madam Deputy
speaker that data from the latest
British social attitude survey out today
shows support in Scotland for the union
is continuing to drop like a stone as
more and more folk recognize that only
Independence offers them hope and a
progressive
thank you madam Deputy speaker well um I
thank her for her kind remarks to uh all
those who contributed to the uh the
morning of our late Queen I know that uh
the house of authorities are considering
how members can uh Express their
gratitude towards staff for what they've
done
um perhaps using the intranet to do that
so all staff can read
um how we feel and how proud We Are of
what they have done
um our prime minister has recommitted uh
us at unga and sent a message to the
world that our resolved towards Ukraine
will not waver that we will continue to
lead the charge on combating Russian
aggression uh and uh that includes the
financial measures that we have been
pioneering and leading others on that
will continue uh and clearly there will
be a time for members to raise this in a
the general debate uh today I can
reassure her that myself the chief and
others have ensured that the time we
have rightly taken uh to mourn her late
Majesty uh does not slow down our
legislative program we uh we are
confident that whether it is on cost of
living measures or on sanctions or any
other matter there will be no real world
delay to those measures uh being brought
forward she asks specifically about the
EU retained law Bill we will bring that
forward for first reading on the 11th of
October and we will continue to push and
speed up the uh legislation whether it
is on growth are all these other
measures that we are bringing to the
floor of the house I would end by saying
that I think all of the four nations of
our United Kingdom have shown uh the
strength there is in Unity over the last
few weeks I think it has been the most
tremendous event a tremendous coming
together and a tremendous welcoming of
our new King King Charles III uh and I
am absolutely confident that public
opinion uh that and the strength of the
United Kingdom will remain strong in all
four nations of this United Kingdom
Karen Bradley thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker may can I welcome my
right honorable friend to her new role
and join her in the tributes that she
paid to the staff and others in this
place who made the lying in states such
as special occasion and she was new to
the job and I must say acted with
Incredible dignity and Grace throughout
as child procedure committee I would
like to extend a warm welcome to her to
come in front of the committee on many
occasions uh during her tenure as Lord
president of the council and also thank
her for announcing that the procedure
committee's report on proxy voting will
be subject to a vote when we return from
the conference recess can I ask her
could she confirm that there will be
time for a debate on that motion and
also will we revert to the traditional
uh way of uh voting on these matters
that this is a free vote and a matter
for the house to decide
um yes I I thank the my right honorable
friend for her kind remarks and can
confirm that we will uh we undertook to
allow a debate on this that is our plan
on the 12th of October clearly these are
matters for the house and they should be
a free vote here's the back bench
business committee Ian Mills very
grateful modern deputies can I thank the
leader of the House for the business
statement but and I know that obviously
circumstances are completely Beyond her
control in terms of what's been
happening over the last few weeks but a
significant amount of parliamentary time
and back bench time has been lost and um
obviously so there's some disappointment
that there isn't any back bench time in
the first week back after the conference
at recess so notwithstanding and
understanding that the government want
to get on with their own agenda could I
just gently remind the leader of the
house that we do have entrained in
standing orders a requirement for a
certain number of days of backbend time
um you know that we have to have and
could also remain members across the
house we would still very much welcome
applications for Westminster Hall
debates which we can allocate time for
as the back bench business
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
raising this uh I know it is incredibly
important to give good notice for not
just allocating time but also when that
will be in order for his committee to
plan and I'm pushing to be able to give
him some information
um in in very short order
to Jeremy Wright thank you very much
speaker I welcome my right handful
friend to her new responsibilities and I
welcome to that at the last prime
minister's question it's our right
honorable friend the Prime Minister
confirmed the government will be
bringing back the Online safety bill can
I ask my right Uncle friend two things
first of all can't you make sure that
that happens urgently this bill has been
carried over once already and there is a
considerable need to get on with it and
secondly and without wishing to cut
across the first can she make sure that
if the tweaks that my right honorable
friend the Prime Minister referred to to
that bill are to be more than cosmetic
but those of us in this house are able
to see them before the bill goes to the
other place
well I thank my right honorable friend
for raising those uh two important
points I know that the new secretary of
state at dcms is looking at the
legislation she wants to bring forward
with with great urgency uh she will have
heard his remarks today but I shall also
write and raise these issues and ask her
to get in touch with the honorable
gentleman who is very knowledgeable
about these issues
Cordova thank you madam Deputy speaker
many households in my constituency have
seen their energy Fields going up by
upwards of 500 as they're on heat
networks which are not regulated by
often now the energy security bill would
make off Germany regulator and introduce
a price cap but there have been reports
that the prime minister is set to either
pause or scrap the bill entirely so can
the leader of the House reassure this
house and my constituents that that bill
will not be scrapped and that a price
cap will be introduced well I Thank The
Honorable lady for raising those
important points businesses will be
announced in the normal way but I'd be
very happy to raise those points uh with
the Secretary of State uh and ask that
he contact her office
have an urgent debate on Hindu phobic
hate crime recent days have seen a
number of appalling acts of intimidation
and harassment directed against the
Hindu Community including a violent mob
targeting a temple and tearing down a
flag with spiritual significance and I
think it is important that these
disgraceful episodes are discussed by
this Parliament
well I thank my right honorable friend
for raising this and we have all seen
some very sad uh sites reported in the
news of uh the uh the tensions and uh
particularly uh in in Leicester which
does not have uh as a city a history of
that nature it has a reputation for
being a very harmonious uh Place indeed
um she will be able to apply for uh
debates in the normal way these the
policing issues are local issues but I
know that the Home Secretary is being
kept informed and all this of course has
played out against that backdrop of
national Unity which makes those events
even more sad here I hope house
could you speak I may I join colleagues
across the house in congratulating
everybody
um who contributed to the outstanding
Arrangements of events in this house
following her late Manchester's death
Madame Deputy speaker parent on
Universal Credit who are full-time
carers for children with live limiting
or life-threatening conditions rely on a
series of additional benefits but they
stop immediately if a child sadly dies
it places a heavy financial burden and
hardship on parents who are already
suffering from extreme stress and grief
as has happened to one of my
constituents will the government make
time for a debate to discuss bereavement
support for parents who have been
full-time carers for children with life
limiting or life-threatening conditions
yeah
well I Thank The Honorable lady both for
her kind remarks about staff and and
others who enabled those amazing events
to uh to occur over the last few weeks
and also for raising this incredibly
important issue she will know that the
new secretary of state at DWP has held
uh this uh particular aspect of that
Department's portfolio and has been very
concerned uh with all aspects of
bereavement and ensuring uh the welfare
system supports people at the at the
right time and is considerate to the
grief that they are experiencing
um the secretary of state will have
heard her remarks today I shall make
sure she does and raise them with her
and she can of course raise this issue
at the next questions uh that that
arises David Mandel
thank you madam Deputy speaker the a
this week at the United Nations General
Assembly President Biden hosted the
seventh uh replenishment conference of
the global fund to fight AIDS TB and
malaria unfortunately the United Kingdom
government was not able uh to make a
pledge as a former International
Development secretary my right honorable
friend will know uh the impact that the
global fund has had in relation to the
eradication of HIV TV and malaria and
therefore will she ensure that the
United Kingdom government comes forward
as soon as possible with a statement on
its intention to contribute to that
replenishment fund
well I thank my right honorable friend
for raising the profile of the global
fund which does do tremendous work and
the UK has been a leader uh in ensuring
that it does have the funds to carry out
this work which benefits us all as well
as the countries it is particularly
focused on the minister for development
um restated uh during that uh
replenishment conference the UK's strong
commitment uh to uh that uh that fund we
continue to be committed to it and we'll
be making an announcement on our pledge
uh in the coming weeks
the leader of the house will be aware
that there have been a number of
Hospital rebuilds in the pipeline for
quite a long time but the money doesn't
seem to be forthcoming from the treasury
in the hole that's been going on for
years now there may be some reference to
this in the statement tomorrow but I
think he's very likely if there isn't
could we have a statement from either a
health minister or a treasury Minister
yeah
um you can have a statement from a
health minister in in nanoseconds the
secretary of state will be at the
dispatch box um The Honorable gentleman
should feel free to raise those issues
uh with her
um but if he has any difficulty in
obtaining Clarity around he'd no doubt
be interested in uh in local schemes uh
I will of course the system in getting
those answers Maggie through yeah Mr
Speaker next Tuesday the 27th of
September I'm holding the air wash jobs
and Community fair 2022. for the first
time since the start of the pandemic
it's an in-person event with local and
Regional businesses attending to promote
the job vacancies and apprenticeship
opportunities that they have
because my relatable friends agree that
we must use whatever levers we have
possible such as job fairs to promote uh
the the importance of having a healthy
and productive Workforce and can we have
a debate in government time to explore
other levers that we can use to ensure
that we have that Workforce that we
really need for productivity well I
thank my honorable friend for for
raising this important issue we have a
great track record in this area very low
unemployment 2 million women uh in work
than there were in uh in 2010 and we've
halved the disability employment gap and
in addition to the work that DWP and
other government departments have been
doing it is very much down to local
engagement things like job fairs and I
know and I would thank the honorable
lady for all the work she has done in
her constituency to support her
constituents finding jobs getting into
work sometimes for the first time
Dame Diana Johnson Deputy speaker and
can I also welcome the bright honorable
lady to her new role
um in light of the leaks to the media
over the last few days could we have a
debate to find out why this government
believes that to make the poor work
harder or try harder we should cut their
benefits but actually to get wealthy
Bankers to work harder we should
increase their bonuses
well the chancellor will be in this
place tomorrow and members will be able
to question him on on what his policies
are rather than speculating about uh
what it has or has not been in the in
the media and I hope that Madam Deputy
speaker and Mr Speaker would approve of
that so John Hayes
Deputy speaker uh since the death of
Queen Elizabeth II
we have witnessed an extraordinary
Nation ydd kingdom-wide response to
moving necks of Sorrow
at our loss and celebration celebration
of a life of remarkable service
so that that mood is marked forever and
Remembrance can last for generations to
come A fitting National Memorial needs
to be established will the leader of the
House therefore agree that a statement
be brought to this house on what formed
that Memorial might take for me a statue
on the final plinth in Trafalgar Square
would be ID
well I thank my right honorable friend
for for his suggestion uh clearly these
will be matters
um uh that will concern many members but
they will involve other bodies outside
of this house but I shall certainly
raise this with the secretary state for
dcms and ensure that she properly
consults members on on their wishes as
plans are taken forward
Caroline Lucas
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
the evidence of the physical and mental
health benefits of greater access to the
countryside is overwhelming yet we only
have a legal right to roam on eight
percent of English land and three
percent of rivers so could we have a
debate in government time on the need to
expand the countryside rights of wayak
to cover Rivers woods and green belt and
will the government support my private
members Bill published today that would
succeed in doing exactly that
well I Thank The Honorable lady for for
raising these issues I hope I'm subject
to uh the Motions on the order paper
today agreeing uh recess dates to very
swiftly uh be able to publish the next
schedule of departmental questions to
enable honorable members to uh to raise
these issues directly with uh the the
Departments but I thank the lady for
making us aware of her private bill
recall fail
you're on page 33 of the conservative
party Manifesto government pledged to
protect Greenfield sites and prioritize
Brownfield sites for development yet in
practice planning inspectors are
overturning local Democratic planning
authorities decisions to refuse building
on Greenfield sites most recent is South
roads in wigglesfield in my constituency
and we have uh Nolan's Farm in Plumpton
and mornings Mill in polegate also
facing a similar fate can we have a
debate in government time about the
commitment to the government's pledge in
its Manifesto and the promise made by
the the prime minister to the father of
the house most recently and the role of
the planning inspector in overturning
these Democratic decisions
I call the legion house
um I do want to try to get everybody in
so it's quite important that the um the
questions are brief leader of the House
during the uh recent leadership contest
the Prime Minister restated her
commitment both to empowering local
people but also keeping our promises uh
in our Manifesto I hope that will give
the honorable lady some comfort uh but
she will obviously be able to question
the prime minister in the usual way and
her voice will have been heard today
Barry Sherman Madame Deputy speaker the
welcome to the new leader of the house I
look forward to meeting you every week
could she very quickly uh make a
statement to the house about the welfare
of the people who work here increasingly
the members of parliament or wearing air
quality detectors are picking up that
this is not a safe environment to work
in something should be done about it
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
raising this issue and look forward to
our weekly meetings uh that he promises
I shall certainly take up the the issue
he raises with house authorities
speaker may I warmly congratulate my
right honorable friend not only in
becoming leader of the house but Lord
president of the council and in that
latter capacity will she urge the privy
Council not to agree to the proposed
change in name of lineker College Oxford
to that of a Vietnamese billionaire who
is proposing to give 155 million pounds
to the college if we want to clean up
this country from Dirty Money and dodgy
donations this would be a good place to
start
well I thank my right honorable friend
for for raising this matter I will
ensure that the department for Education
uh will have heard uh what he uh says I
suspect that is the uh um the more
appropriate and uh swiftest way of
resolving the issues that are of
concerned to him
because my of interesting constituent
Jamie Lee fieldings nearly seven months
pregnant has gestational diabetes and
despite having paid the phone the
Spanish authorities in Tenerife are
holding her and removing vital food and
medication and breaching her human
rights she has a very short window to
get home to have her baby well the
leader of the House Press the foreign
secretary to help get Jamie Lee home and
meet with me so that I can do everything
I can to make sure that she's safe
healthy and home as soon as possible
well I Thank The Honorable lady for
raising the plight of her constituents
and I will certainly do that I will
raise this with the foreign office and
urge them to be in touch with with the
honorable lady bob Blackman imagine
Deputy speaker and I joined with my
right old friend the member for chipping
Barnet in condemning the violent attacks
made on Hindu temples in Leicester and
smethwick only just last night
but next week the Hindu festival of
navaratri begins and on the 24th of
October we will celebrate Diwali and the
following day Hindu New Year the Hindu
community in this country are seriously
concerned about their safety in going
about their celebrations so could my
right of a friend arrange for an urgent
statement to be made by the new Home
Secretary on what arrangements are going
to be made to make sure that our Hindu
friends and neighbors are able to
celebrate their religion in peace and
Harmony as they've always done
well my honorable friend raises a very
important point and as he stresses this
is also a very timely issue as well I
will certainly take that up with the
Home Secretary Barbara Keely
this week the government's 150 pound
cost of living payments to disabled
people starting to go out but unpaid
carers like Katie Styles have said that
that amount won't scratch the surface of
what is needed Katie's husband Mark
Styles has a rare form of motor neuron
disease and like many disabled people
relies on equipment which uses
electricity and on his home being kept
warmer so he doesn't get chest
infections this is a widespread issue
for disabled people and they unpaid
family carers so can we have a debate in
government time so that we can raise
these issues with ministers
have I Thank The Honorable lady for
raising this important issue it is a
matter for the Department for work and
pensions but also for the Department for
Health and Social care
um the Secretary of State for that
latter department will be in the in the
house shortly she should raise that with
with her
um or in the in the usual way but I
shall certainly make sure both
departments are aware of the honorable
lady's concerns
my name David I agree with the right to
honorable honorable friends who have
spoken in Praise over the uh the the
scenes that we've seen in the last
extraordinary scenes that we've seen
over the last uh two weeks now we're
more so of course than a microcision
city of West aberdeenshire and cardamom
the world saw the community of royalty
so I pay tribute to her late Majesty she
was taken from Balmoral on her final
Journey a lot of the ceremonial of those
two weeks were organized by a lot of
lieutenants across the country who
remain on page so I wondered if my uh my
writable friend would agree to a debate
in government time on the Scottish
national party government's austerity
agenda which not only is slashing uh
millions of pounds from education in
Scotland from government is called but
also tens of thousands of pounds from
the budgets of the Lord of tenants who
plays such a crucial role in our
national life as has only just been
proven over the last two weeks yeah
[Music]
well if the
Scottish nationalist party
is a is clearly obsessed with with
issues that are of little concern to the
people of Scotland uh in terms of their
Public Services their ability to access
health care or get their bins emptied or
any of the other things that the the
party is is dropping the ball on but I
do think that these Services uh that are
provided that uh that focal point for
communities and also the link to our
royal family are incredibly important
and should be preserved and cherished in
Paisley uh Madam Deputy speaker the
leader of the House must be alarmed
at what happened in Hong Kong on Monday
evening when a citizen there paid
respect to our late Majesty the queen
and has been arrested under the Sedition
loss I'm wondering if any
representations have been made by this
government to the Hong Kong or sorry to
the Chinese Embassy here about that
seems to be a terrible way to treat a
citizen of Hong Kong it is well he I I
Thank The Honorable gentleman for
raising that uh appalling event that I'm
sure would have dismayed every member of
this house I shall certainly ask the
foreign office to contact uh The
Honorable gentleman to confirm what has
been done in the wake of that and a fur
I would like to also add my thanks to
everyone in this house for the brilliant
National commemorative events May I take
a moment Madam Deputy speaker to thank
those locally uh who worked so hard as
well to make our local events in South
and West so dignified the mayor the
council offices community group church
leaders the police and the scouts
would I agree with my honorable friend
who's asked for a national debate on
permanent tributes to her late Majesty
would my honorable friend agree with
chalkboard lifeguards who are already
suggesting a Queen Elizabeth II
life-saving award in honor of their late
Patron
well I will join with my honorable
friend in thanking everyone across the
the country who did so much to enable
all our communities to properly pay
tribute and and mourn uh the loss of our
our great Queen she is gone but her
values still remain with us and I think
there will be a huge interest not just
in uh in a a permanent Memorial to her
but also in many schemes that are
strengthening our communities and
bringing people together as she did in
life Janet Davey thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaker many of my
constituents in lewishameys live in
buildings with District heating networks
they are not covered by the energy price
cap with some pain 13 times the energy
cap similar to my honorable friend from
Battersea I was alarmed to see reports
that the energy bill which could put in
place regulation for heating networks
may be halted or dropped could the
leader of the House ask the business
secretary to come to the floor to
clarify the future of this legislation
specifically on this issue
well I know of many honorable members
have put questions to the the business
secretary uh earlier today I will
certainly raise this specific issues
that she does with him um but business
will be announced in the usual way
Danny Krueger
thank you speaker does my right
honorable friend share my deep concern
about the decision of PayPal the online
payments company to cancel the accounts
of certain organizations including us
for them who campaigned against the
covert lockdowns and perhaps most
ironically the Free Speech Union who
appeared to have been targeted because
of their views on sex and gender as we
move towards the cashless economy these
companies form partially essential
infrastructure of of ordinary life and
will the government take steps to ensure
that they cannot discriminate against
individuals or organizations on the
basis of perfectly legal political views
so the
[Applause]
The Honorable gentleman may have further
information than than I do about why the
PayPal had canceled uh the account in
that facility from the organizations
that he mentions but from what I
understand
um the Free Speech Union and other
organizations are also still in the dark
about exactly why they have had those
Services removed from them despite
making great efforts to find out and I
think this is a common theme amongst our
casework for many members in this house
whether it's canceling contracts uh
whether it is uh trying to get a an
error resolved with firms it is very
difficult for people to speak directly
to someone to try and get a situation
resolved or make a decision about uh
reorganizing how they're going to in in
the case that he raises uh make those
payments I think that that is a very
good uh topic for a debate and I would
encourage honorable members who are
concerned about customer services in
some of these organizations to to bring
it forward and ask for a debate in the
usual way Trisha Gibson
Adam Deputy speaker
he already live in fuel poverty with a
current cap price of
1971 pounds well the leader of the House
make a statement setting out if she
believes an energy cap Rising by another
600 pounds helps her householders such
as those in my constituency of North
Ayrshire and Aaron who already cannot
afford to pay their energy bills as well
as householders who will shortly find
themselves added to these sorry numbers
and fuel poverty as a direct result of
this new increase in the price cap
well she The Honorable lady will know
that we have acted swiftly to bring
forward measures to help both households
and businesses with the rising cost of
energy but this government is also going
to address the underlying issues which
are exacerbating the problem uh one has
been announced today and the business
secretary has answered an urgent
question on it and I would urge all
members of this house to also
concentrate on the issues which will
help us increase supply of energy as
well as controlling the costs
their ambulance is a vital service for
many areas of the United Kingdom but no
more so in the rural areas of mid Wales
the Welsh air ambulance is a great
charity and very dear to my constituents
hearts and something we spot all year
round they're however reconfiguring the
bases and the the the air ambulance at
welshpool airport that we're very very
proud of looks to be moved more North
could I ask for a debate in government
time around the funding and coverage of
air ambulances because this important
service is incredibly important to rural
Wales and we must keep it
must be brief I want to get everybody in
leader of the House
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
raising this uh important issue we often
forget that this incredible service that
is provided across the country by many
organizations there are in fact uh
Charities uh it's right that local
people uh have input on to how these uh
services are running uh in that area and
he will know that as a government we
have uh changed our treatment uh of uh
air ambulances to ensure that they are
able to financially Thrive but I thank
him for raising these important points
today
does the government still intend to
bring forward legislation in this
Parliament to amend repeal or replace
the human rights act or to constrain the
independence of the Judiciary by further
restricting judicial review
announced in the normal way
Layla Moran
historic Wars Hill in my Oxford
constituency is facing the prospect of a
grossly inappropriate development Peking
University HSBC business school which is
owned by the Chinese Communist Party
have submitted a planning application to
vastly expand the campus at foxcombe
Hall now the planning committee has
narrowly approved the application when
economic benefit against the loss of the
green belt but as far as I can see the
main beneficiary of any economic
activity is the Chinese State and not
the local area
Our Hope now sits with the Secretary of
State for leveling up who has the right
to call it in but with recesses and no
questions many letters written I'm
desperate for a meeting with him and his
officials to explain why this is the
wrong choice both locally and nationally
well I'm aware that the honorable lady
has made a formal request
um for this planning application to be
called in by the for the Secretary of
State's consideration that may limit
some of the conversations she might be
able to have with him but I will uh
write to him uh seeking guidance from
his Department about what is the most
appropriate way for the honorable 82 be
engaged on this and further to the
comments I made earlier to my honorable
friend for the New Forest uh she should
also raise this with the department for
Education Nick Smith
Madam Deputy speaker the prime
minister's Chief of Staff has been
interviewed by the FBI in connection
with electoral bribery in Puerto Rico so
could we please have a government
statement on this to consider if any UK
laws may have been broken the FBI
interview has affected the chief of
staff's security status
and whether the Prime Minister was
informed of the FBI interview before her
chief of staff's appointment was
confirmed
well I will refer The Honorable
gentleman to statements that have been
issued on this matter I don't think it
is an issue that should be debated at
length on the floor of this house
and I can assure him that everything
that you would expect him to do is being
done but I don't think it is a matter
for debate here
foreign
trust figures this summer showed that
Ford in 10 of those on universal credits
were already skipping meals given that
there is going to be another price hike
in the next few days does the leader of
the House expect to be timetabling in
yet another fiscal statement or does she
expect our constituents to Simply starve
yes oh yeah yeah well I would uh suggest
that the honorable lady uh comes to the
house tomorrow and raises issues
directly uh with the chancellor I know
it is his intention to set out the plan
for growth and how this will assist her
constituents and she will have ample
time to be able to question him then and
in the future
Grand Mars thank you I'd like to ask
about the government's commitment to
transparency in the protection of
whistleblowers whistle blows like my
constituent Paul Calvers have been left
in limbo suffering great stress and many
bereaved families are questioning the
decision to appoint NHS inside a damn
Marianne Griffiths to lead the review
into systematic cover-ups by the
Northeast Ambulance Service
can we have a statement or a general
debate in government time on the
protection of whistleblowers and on
ensuring transparency in the public
service so that we can learn any lessons
that need to be learned thank you well
The Honorable gentleman raises an
important constituency matter which I
will be happy to raise with the
Secretary of State for health but he's
right we owe people who
whistleblow a huge debt and they need to
be protected
anyways speaker there used to be two
trains an hour from penge West and
Annalee stations in my constituency to
London Bridge now there are none and
from Sydenham and Forest Hill stations
the number has halved go via Thames link
tell me that due to a reduction of
government funding in the 2021 spending
review they've had to cut to capacity
but it's having a huge impact on my
constituents their ability to access
employment education and health care so
can we please have a debate in
government time about support for
Regional Rail networks
well this government has done a huge
amount to support uh not just existing
uh rail but also build new schemes and
helping our towns and cities uh connect
in in ways they if not before but I
would also just urge The Honorable lady
that she may wish to raise this at the
next transport questions is on the 13th
of October who Henry Deputy speaker a
number of my constituents have contacted
me to complete mean that the financial
conduct Authority have failed to protect
them from false investment scams
including so-called mini bonds the ifs
this is despite flags being raised and
the FCA has accredited and listed
companies despite directors not actually
being real people the fce rules are
clearly unfit for purpose can we have a
debate in government time on how to
reform the rules and provide some
genuine protection for those who've been
targeted The Honorable gentleman raises
a very important issue which I'm sure
will be of concern to many members in
this house I would urge him to raise
this at the next treasury questions
which is on the 11th of October but I
shall certainly make sure the treasury
have heard what he's said today Steven
doubted up to speak
thousands of constituents in Cardiff
South Africa live in blocks of
apartments that are affected by Fire and
Building Safety defects as well as
needing to get the defects fixed many of
them are unfortunately facing spiraling
Insurance costs and also a failure to
see the government's guidance to lenders
being implemented by lenders in the
ability to get mortgages and so on
because we have a statement from the new
Minister for housing
urgent or one of the treasury ministers
so we can debate these important issues
well I would
encourage the honorable gentleman to
raise that matter with with both
departments but also some of the issues
he touches on are aren't evolved
the death of masamini in Iran for
allegedly breaking hijab rules
um was shocking as was the Iranian
Authority's response to the subsequent
protests
um can we have a statement from the
government and the support they are
providing to Human Rights activists in
Iran including those who have to seek
Asylum here in the UK
well I'm sure that all members of this
house would want to Echo the comments
that The Honorable lady has made it was
it was the most barbaric and appalling
act and has caused a huge amount of
disquiet and clearly there are
repercussions uh on uh unfurling now uh
in in Iran I shall certainly make sure
that the fcdo respond to the honorable
lady's concerns and I would encourage
all members who want to put a spotlight
on what is going on and to send a
message message to people who are
struggling against a very repressive
regime are that we can apply for a
debate in the usual way don't say
shallow me thank
you thanks may be aware that there have
been almost 3 600 cases of monkey pox in
the UK one of the highest in Europe
experts including British Association
for HIV and Sexual Health Terence
Higgins trust National AIDS trust and
prepster have said without any action
monkeypox could be endemic in the UK the
public health response has been far too
slow from this government yeah can we
have an urgent statement from the
government so if you get a grip on this
situation and ensure that no one is Left
Behind
well I shall certainly make sure that
the Secretary of State for health uh
hears what the honorable lady has said
the government clearly has done some
things to try and in particular raise
awareness and give Health advice on on
this matter but I shall raise it with uh
with that relevant Department and ask
her to the new secretary of state to get
in touch with the honorable lady Chris
Stevens
okay to speak in a couple of weeks have
a lot so can I ask the leader of the
house uh when the government intends to
lay down a second remedial order on
bereavement support payments for
cohabiting couples given the courts to
say that four years ago these payments
should happen and all that remedial
order replaced before recess tomorrow
so I have raised this matter from memory
with the relevant department and I will
follow that up and make sure that
they're in touch with the honorable
gentleman's office Andrew Green thank
you can I welcome the leader of the
house to her new position and urger to
use that position to secure a debate in
government time on leveling up it was
the Mantra of the previous
administration and those of us with
local authorities that have bid for the
latest round of the leveling up fund
we're keen to be able to promote our
schemes I in particular want to promote
tankside Council scheme for Denton
Denton Denton so can we get that shot
well I congratulate The Honorable
gentleman for doing precisely that this
morning he will know that the prime
minister is still committed to this
agenda and he will have an opportunity
tomorrow uh to raise any issues he
wishes with the chancellor because
clearly this is also about growth
the benefit cap is twice as popular as
scrapping the cap on Bankers bonuses
actually the benefit cap which has been
frozen since 2016 would put an average
of 65 pounds per week in the pocket of
families can so can we have a debate in
government timing the importance of
supporting struggling families in
Glasgow Central rather than attorneys
helping their wealthy Bank her Pals in
the city of London
well again I would uh encourage the
honorable lady to uh show up tomorrow
and put questions directly to the
chancellor but I would urge all
honorable members not to get too excited
about things they read in the Press uh
and wait till they hear what the
chancellor has to say
Japan government said inheritance tax
does not have to be paid on the transfer
of assets from One Sovereign to another
at the time the then leader of the
opposition the late John Smith asked
although it is accepted that assets held
by the queen as Sovereign should not be
liable to inheritance tax will the Prime
Minister explain why all private assets
passing from One Sovereign to the next
should also be exempt I think that this
remains a legitimate question so would
the leader of the House allow time for
discussion on this matter
well I think if the honorable gentleman
would like to write to me with the
specifics of what he is concerned about
I would be very happy to find the best
way that we could raise this as an issue
and give him some certainty uh so that
he could apply for a debate
Adam deputies because the government's
Manifesto promoted leveling up but now
seems without a mandate to be pivoting
our Focus to uh trickle-down economics
given IMF has said that making an
electric job does not drive growth and
President Biden treated he was sick and
tired of trickle-down Economics it has
never worked kind of a debate on the
utter failure of chuckledown Economics
favored by Ronald Reagan and Margaret
Thatcher
well I would first of all
um Point uh to the fact that our support
package uh 37 billion uh to uh enable
people to uh cope with the uh the cost
of living uh could not be described as a
trickle uh in any uh in any respect uh
but I think that rather than a lot of
commentary uh about economic plans what
the people of this country want to see
is some action and that is what they are
going to get tomorrow and I would
encourage him to come to the house and
listen to the chancellor it's your math
School
short term holiday left so for the last
few years and particularly the last few
months is fueling the housing crisis in
York but also the cost of living crisis
too so could we have a debate in order
to discuss the licensing which needs to
be introduced to curb the industry and
ensure that our constituents have the
preference and access to housing I Thank
The Honorable lady I will certainly
raise this with the relevant department
and when the next schedule of questions
are published I'd encourage her to come
to the house and and ask the Secretary
of State
Patrick Grady
speaker I welcome our confirmation that
a statement on the UK's contribution to
the global fund is going to be
forthcoming but I wonder if we could
have a wider debate on UK Eid spending
particularly the pressures on the budget
given the decision to go from 0.7 to 0.5
percent and particularly how we can make
sure that support for Ukraine is
additional and not instead of existing
each plans
yeah
again uh he has an opportunity tomorrow
to raise these issues directly with the
chancellor we have had a fairly recent
uh debates uh around uh the the aid
budget but uh I'm sure that uh when the
announcement which is imminent uh for
the global fund is is made there will be
further opportunities to question
ministers about that because team
Wakefield
speak of the infield sense of mental
health units in prestwich in my
constituency is due to be subject to a
police investigation following a
panorama investigation due to the
mistreatment of patients following these
devastating uh announcements would the
leader of the House be able to arrange
fiber a statement from the health
secretary or to be able to arrange for a
meeting with me so I can discuss these
concerns with board
have he raises a very important point I
know that the department for Health and
Social care has done a lot of work in
recent weeks with regard to making sure
that care settings for individuals are
appropriate for them and clearly this is
a an immediate case for The Honorable
gentleman and I would urge him to raise
this directly with the secretary of
state and I shall make sure she is aware
of his concerns president Oswald
September is Childhood Cancer Awareness
Month and I'm grateful to members across
the house who've signed my early day
motion noting that it's unsurprising
they've done so because this issue sadly
affects every constituency in Scotland
and across the UK and while
um there have been improvements and
outcomes for children with cancer these
have not been significant enough in some
treatments have not advanced in 40 years
can I ask the leader of the House
therefore if we can have a debate in
government time on how the UK government
can support the Improvement in an
increase in levels of research and
whether members across the house will
support will it goal day tomorrow to
support Childhood Cancer Awareness Month
Thank The Honorable lady for raising
awareness of that important day and I'm
sure all members of this house would
want to support the the aims which she
sets out the government has clearly has
done a huge amount in terms of advancing
Partnerships in life science between
academic institutes but also the charity
sector as well reforms on intellectual
shared intellectual property for example
and we will continue to do that as part
of our growth plan
you care and I welcome the rubber lady
to her new position and hope that the
last few months of inertia will finally
be behind us among the many important
issues committed to in the government's
2019 Manifesto but which we have seen
scant sign of any progress on is the
long promised employment bill
become the leader of the House therefore
outline when we can expect to see this
important legislation timetabled so we
can end the race to the bottom in
employment rights in this country
exacerbated by our current economic
crisis
well I would first of all challenge what
she says about this country's record on
our employment rights we have tended to
lead the world and certainly lead Europe
uh with regard to uh that I'd also
challenge her description of a summer of
inertia the very fact that on the first
uh occasion possible we have brought
forward measures on cost of living and
tackling uh the cost of energy she's
shortly going to get a statement from
the new secretary of state for health on
on our plans to assist Health and Social
care and also the plan for growth which
is being unveiled by the new Chancellor
tomorrow that has not just been pulled
out of a hat a huge amount of work has
been done across the summer including by
the former Chancellor the now Chancellor
Duchess of Lancaster be announced in the
normal way so I'd like to thank the
leader of the House for making time
today to debate the situation in Ukraine
but in the last few weeks we've seen
escalation of military violence on
between Armenia and Azerbaijan and also
uh on the border between Kosovo and
Serbia we know that there has been some
Russian involvement although not
directly in these conflicts will the
leader of the House make time to debate
wider uh conflict zones through Europe
and Central Asia
I'm sure all honorable honorables will
have been very disturbed by some of the
reports of violence but also violation
of dead bodies uh very very horrific uh
things I should certainly make sure that
the fcda are aware of members concerns
and I would encourage him to put these
questions directly to the new foreign
secretary Chris law
all right thank you madam Deputy speaker
verified videos by Human Rights Watch
graphically illustrate the brutality and
barbarism of azerbaijan's recent attack
on Armenia showing an elderly Armenian
civilian decapitated with a knife and
his head mounted on the carcass of a pig
and the mutilated corpse of a female
Armenian Soldier the rise guys that
ghost out and replaced by Stones it
should be noted Azerbaijan is also
backed heavily by NATO member turkey
with one Turkish political leader
stating last week and I quote I remind
you once again the Turkish nation has a
power to erase Armenia from history and
geography so can we have an urgent
debate in government time on illegal
attacks by Azerbaijan on the Democracy
of Armenia and a statement from the UK
government condemning all those
supporting these horrific actions and
hate speech
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
raising uh being the second member to
raise these issues I will certainly take
this up with the new foreign secretary
speaker today the National Education
Union and the mirror have re-launched
their no tide Left Behind Campaign which
calls on urgent action for child poverty
so can the leader of the House call on
the Secretary of State for education to
roll out free Universal School meals to
at least all children in Primary School
to prevent children from going hungry
I will certainly raise what the
honorable lady says with the with the
new secretary of state and I would also
encourage her uh to put those questions
directly to him at the next round of
questions Catherine West
the bank of England statement this
morning that interest rates are to go up
again and in light of food inflation
going through the roof and the
burgeoning government debt which is
dragging us all down will the leader of
the House make it a priority for us to
debate in government time how we're
going to pay this debt back will it be
our grandchildren or will it be the
grandchildren of our grandchildren who
will be able to pay back the enormous
debts which this government is accruing
this week in its decisions
well The Honorable lady will know that
the chancellor will be here tomorrow to
take questions from from all members in
this house but in addition to the very
considerable support packages that have
been put in place for for both
households and businesses the answer to
the problems she raises is about getting
growth back into our economy and that is
what this government is going to be
focused on and what she will hear from
the chancellor tomorrow
Jim Shannon speaker I know that the the
leader of the House shares my
appreciation and gratitude for the life
of service given by Harriet Majesty the
Queen Elizabeth she was a lady of great
faith and who greatly respected other
people of other faiths will the leader
of the House enable a statement on what
our government plans to do for advances
in the rights of freedom of religion or
belief and the interconnectedness of
freedom of religion or belief to all
human rights and its relevance to
foreign policy and trade
well I thank the The Honorable gentleman
for raising this important matter uh yes
she was not just a beacon for that
within the United Kingdom uh but also uh
throughout the Commonwealth and the and
the wider world uh and I shall certainly
encourage the foreign secretary to get
in touch with the honorable gentleman
about how we can continue the work of
our Envoy that we have appointed on
religious freedom and the other programs
that the fcdo is doing
speaker back in June the leader's
predecessor joined me in congratulating
a team boxer from blantire in my
constituency will the new leader join me
in congratulating young Jacob Naismith
again after his historic win of the 46
kilo eubc schools clown in Turkey this
summer making him the youngest
competitor to to to ever do so and can
we have a debate in government time on
the importance of local youth sporting
groups in in our communities across the
UK
well I'm delighted to be able to join
The Honorable lady in congratulating uh
Jacob in his achievements in one of the
toughest uh Sports uh going and I know
that the new secretary of state at dcms
is very passionate about the sporting
agenda for particularly young people and
children and will want to ensure that we
are building and bringing forward
schemes to encourage physical activity
and excellence in sport
I thank the leader of the House for
answering the business questions uh
statement Secretary of State for Health
and Social care there is coffee
well thank you mad and dirty speaker and
I'm pleased today to set out to
Parliament our plan for patience
as the Prime Minister said on the
doorsteps of Downing Street she had
three clear priorities growing the
economy tackling energy security and
support for households and businesses
and the NHS with patients being able to
get